Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Apokalyptische Geräusche im Hintergrund deuten darauf hin, dass hier das Chaos Radio ist.
Das Internet hat wieder recht.
Das Internet hat recht. Hier ist Chaos Radio 114. Wir haben es im Internet nachgeschlagen. Da stand das. Im Internet steht ja alles. Chaos Radio 114 beschäftigt sich mit, der Pawel, was stand noch?
Software Projektmanagement.
Sag's nochmal bitte. Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Guck im Internet nach.
Software Projektmanagement.
Genau, das ist jetzt Pawel, der jetzt mantra-mäßig den Titel der Sendung runterbieten wird, solange wir es alle begriffen haben.
Die Stimme, die eben Pawel angekündigt hat, war Tims Stimme, außerdem ist Harald noch da, der sagt wie immer, nix hab ich gesagt sozusagen.
Der sagt immer Mahlzeit.
Mahlzeit Software Projektmanagement.
Mahlzeit.
Software Projektmanagement.
Worum ging es noch gleich?
Mahlzeit.
Software Projekt Management. Software Projekt Management.
Schalte ihn aus.
Ich dachte, Pavel macht jetzt weiter und ich blende ihn langsam ab. Das kriegt bestimmt total Sinn.
Wollen wir nicht über Fußball reden?
Ja, aber dann muss das im Internet ändern. Da muss sich das Internet anpassen.
Ja.
So, hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio. Ausgabenummer hast du schon gesagt?
114. Das geht um... Pavel ist nicht irgendwie... Da muss ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit bitte dieser Sendung geben. Um, also um ist immer so, fast immer ein Stichwort zu sagen...
Das ist der Pavel Lofschuhhund.
Der Pavel Lofschuhhund.
Ja, also wir greifen hier, wir greifen mal ein Thema auf, was uns vorgeschlagen wurde.
Lass mich raten, im Internet.
Oh ja, im Internet. Und zwar in unseren tollen Mitmachseiten, die immer noch in der Wikipedia residieren, zum höchsten Unbild der Wikipedia-Gemeinde. Die Wikipedia-Gemeinde ist ja gespalten in zwei Lager. Ach echt? Ja, da gibt es die Includisten und die Excludisten. Die behaken sich.
Und was sind die einen und was sind die anderen?
Na die Includisten sind der Meinung, alles muss rein, was in irgendeiner Form zu erzählen ist. Und die anderen argumentieren immer damit, das wäre ja nicht enzyklopädisch. Und man könne ja nicht alles da reinschreiben, wo wir denn dahin kommen.
Ja, aber ist doch Platz genug oder nicht?
Das ist das Argument der Includisten. Das Argument der Excludisten ist, dass wenn man jetzt alles reinmacht, dann würde man ja sozusagen die gesamten Internetinhalte auch dort reingießen können. Das kann ja nicht der Sinn einer dedizierten Webseite sein, die versucht eben was bestimmtes zu machen.
Aber die Idee ist doch, dass es redigiert ist und nicht irgendwie, also sich selbst redigiert.
Du kannst dich gerne in diese Diskussion einklinken. Sie ist etwas länger, sie wird auch schon seit einiger Zeit geführt und mit Inbrunst. Echt, Inbrunst? Ich verstehe die Argumente der einen und der anderen tendiere aber eher zum Inkludismus. Was nicht heißt, dass jetzt die Chaosradio Seiten in der Wikipedia besonders gut platziert sind, weil es nimmt uns natürlich auch eine gewisse Gestaltungsfreiheit. Weil es natürlich schon was anderes, wenn es das eigene Wiki ist. Nur wir haben gerade irgendwie einfach zu wenig Zeit und technisch, keine Ahnung, also auf Chaosradio.cd haben wir einfach bisher das Wiki noch nicht in dem Maße zum Laufen bekommen, wie wir es gerne hätten. Aber wir ziehen da um und so. Und wenn jetzt jemand von der Wikipedia zuhört.
Also von den Excludisten Wikipedia.
Wir kümmern uns ja von den Excludisten und die Includisten, finden das ja toll. Ich fand das auch wirklich ein sehr interessantes Experiment, weil wir haben das ja gemacht seinerzeit zu der Wikipedia-Sendung eben. Und dann haben wir damit angefangen. Und das Schöne ist, dass du natürlich da erstmal eine große Userbase drin hast und vor allem diese ganzen Begriffe sind halt relativ nah. Das heißt, wenn man halt über irgendwas schreibt und auf irgendeinen Begriff hinweist in Bezug auf das Thema der Sendung oder wie auch immer, auch als Feedback, dann kann man halt einfach direkt drauf linken. Und das war ja auch...
Und außerdem residiert das Ganze ja auch noch in einem eigenen Namensraum. Insofern kann man es jetzt nicht direkt mit den normalen Artikeln verwechseln, sondern das ist ja, glaube ich, Unterbenutzer Tim Prittloff Chaosradio, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Was auch nicht der optimale Ort ist. Es ist halt immer so mit diesen... Ich mach das mal eben mal da hin und dann, nicht wahr, dann hat man das.
Und die Interesse war froh, dass Apple Spotlight erfunden hat.
Wobei wir bei dem Thema Projektmanagement wären, nicht wahr?
Oh ja, ein bisschen.
Na jetzt hast du aber Pavel den Text geklaut, nicht wahr?
Na, ich meine ja nur, man macht das halt mal so dahin und da sind wir schon gleich bei einem Primaeinstieg in die Softwareentwicklung hinein. Weil viele Leute rotzen halt mal eben so irgendwie ein bisschen Code irgendwohin und der lebt dann da. Und die Leute müssen sich mit den Fehlern und den Problemen und den Bugs irgendwie herumschlagen.
Genau, das trifft sich dann fest.
Ja, zum Beispiel, gibt es ein prominentes Beispiel, wo es sich festgetreten hat?
Unix. Der Erfinder von Unix, der Ken Thompson, der ist immer mal gefragt worden, was er denn anders machen würde, wenn er jetzt noch mal anfangen könnte. Und dann meint er so, na ja, eigentlich nichts, außer, dass er die eine Funktion, die er CREATE genannt hat, die würde er CREATE nennen, da hat er irgendwie das E vergessen. Das hatte eigentlich auch damals schon keinen Grund, weil Sechszeichen, Namenslänge wären auch schon damals kein Problem gewesen. Bloß aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat er es halt nicht gemacht. Aber ansonsten würde es genauso machen. Was eine ganze Menge darüber aussagt, wie Programmierer so an die Sache herangehen.
Warte, ich bin ja jetzt kein Programmierer. Das ist wahrscheinlich, ist das jetzt gerade wahnsinnig witzig gewesen.
Ach so, also sofern wir es jetzt einfach keinen Unterschied macht. Er hat halt einfach eine Funktion, die etwas erzeugt, nämlich Create. Nicht Create genannt, sondern Create ohne das E am Ende.
Ja klar.
Und er meinte, das würde er halt ändern. Aber ansonsten eben gar nichts, obwohl es natürlich noch 1000 andere Sachen geht, über die man diskutieren könnte. Gerade wenn man 30 Jahre zurückblickt auf ein Betriebssystem, ja was einfach das einflussreichste Betriebssystem auch gewesen ist eigentlich.
Das heißt, wenn Fefe sagt, dass das alles so toll ist, dann lügt er.
Dazu will ich mich jetzt nicht äußern.
Also ich vertrete da ja auch eine andere Meinung als Tim, aber.
Wer schlicht da?
Ich bin so ein Anrufer.
Du bist ein Anrufer?
Genau.
Ja sag doch mal. Du meinst bei Unix?
Ja, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Also ich glaube, wir sollten dann doch mal.
Gut, dann kommen wir zum Thema Software Projektmanagement.
Genau, Pavel, dann komm du doch mal auf das Thema. Also wir wollten eigentlich, um dir gleich mal das Wort wieder zu entziehen. Wir wollten auf einmal einen Einstieg wagen. Du musstest ja die ganze Zeit in deiner Telefonkonferenz rum sitzen. Oder hast du einen schönen Einstieg für uns?
Ich wollte jetzt gerne über Unix reden.
Nee, das ist gut, mach.
Ja, mir fiel nur ein, dass Unix ja eigentlich als Parodie auf Multix begonnen hatte und man sich eigentlich fragt, ob das überhaupt ernst gemeint war seinerzeit oder ob es sich eigentlich nur um einen ernst gewordenen Scherz handelt. Aber damit reicht es jetzt auch. Und wir kommen jetzt zum Thema Software Projektmanagement.
Ich sehe schon Holger wird jetzt ganz unruhig. Also Holger.
Was?
Also wir haben das Thema gewählt, weil es eigentlich ein sehr weitreichendes Thema ist. Und man kann da verschiedene Sachen beleuchten. Und das wollen wir eigentlich auch versuchen. Vor allem gibt es natürlich sehr viele technische Aspekte, was für Werkzeuge man so wählen kann, um Softwareprojekte wirklich ins Leben zu rufen. Und dann auch mit Erfolg durchzuführen und zum Ende zu bringen, wenn sowas überhaupt zu erreichen ist heutzutage. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es aber auch vor allem eine soziale Komponente. Das heißt, wie geht man eigentlich nun daran und wie schafft man das vor allem in einer größeren Gruppe, so ein Projekt erfolgreich zu machen? Und heute haben wir es ja mit zwei grundsätzlichen Modellen zu tun. Das heißt, entweder man entwickelt Software in geschlossenen Gruppen, also in Firmen zum Beispiel oder in Projekten in irgendeiner Form oder eben in diesem offenen Prozess der Open- oder Free-Open-Software-Bewegung, wo nochmal ganz andere Parameter greifen, weil man dort eben häufig die Leute eben auch nicht direkt trifft. Also in einer kleinen Gruppe oder so in einer Firma, da trifft man sich ja in der Regel und kann sich in die Augen gucken. Aber Open-Source-Entwicklung sieht es ja da ganz anders aus. Fabel ist ein Vertreter der geschlossenen Benutzergruppe, so in seiner täglichen Arbeit. Und Harald macht mit beim Netfilter-Projekt bei Linux. Das ist so einer der Netzwerkteile des Linux-Betriebssystems. Und von daher sind es hier auch die Vertreter dieser beiden Modelle.
Dann find ich's hübsch, wenn Fabel erklären würde, was an Haralds Modell das Gute ist und umgekehrt. Was sind die Nachteile der Arbeitsweise, die du machst?
Dass man halt einfach jeden Tag Software entwickeln muss. Dass man in der Regel pünktlich damit beginnen muss. Aber der Vorteil ist, dass man halt Geld dafür bekommt. Das ist dann durchaus seine Vorteile. Nein, Open Source Software Entwicklung ist eher anders motiviert. Es ist mehr selbst motiviert, geht mehr von, da muss der Spaß an der Freude stimmen. Es gibt einfach viele Dinge, die machen nicht unbedingt Spaß. Und es gibt halt auch bei der kommerziellen Softwareentwicklung einfach Termine, Deadlines, die man hat, Ziele, Kunden, Auftraggeber. Das ist einfach ein anderer Zweck. Insofern ist es nicht das eine oder das andere, sondern es ist der Kontext, in dem das Ganze stattfindet und die Motivation, warum man das tut. Und beides ist wichtig. Und es gibt auch fließende Grenzen zwischen beiden Bereichen. Auch wir nutzen Open Source Software. Und auch wir finden es durchaus interessant, bestimmte Dinge in die Community zu geben. Das ist natürlich auch für jeden Softwareentwickler ein gutes Gefühl und eine Motivation, wenn die Software, die er macht, von vielen Leuten benutzt wird. Das ist einfach ein gutes Gefühl und Motivation für sich.
Hält die Community, in die ihr eure, in so einem geschlossenen Kreis entwickelte Software gebt, sich an Termine? Oder lachen die euch aus, wenn ihr sagt, macht mal mit, aber werdet fertig bis zum Ende.
Ich meine, wenn man mal sich Open Source Projekte oder viele Open Source Projekte genau anguckt, dann stellt man oft fest, dass es einen kleinen, harten Kern gibt, der oft sogar in der seinen Ausgangspunkt in einer kommerziellen Softwareentwicklung mal gehabt hat, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen dann sich verselbstständigt hat oder ausgesetzt wurde irgendwann, weil das Unternehmen nicht mehr weiter existiert und dann als Open Source Projekt weitergeführt wurde. Also auch da ist... Firefox, Open Office, Blender.
Also es gibt da sehr viele Beispiele. Und zwar sowohl Beispiele, wo es sozusagen aus der Not war, so ein bisschen wie bei Netscape, wo er irgendwie eingesehen hat, jetzt geht es ja irgendwie echt nicht weiter. Wir müssen jetzt einfach den offenen Prozess machen. Und dann so eine Firma wie Blender, das ist diese 3D Software. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie es denen finanziell ging.
Die sind in Konkurs gegangen. Und dann wurde aus Spendenmitteln die Rechte aus der Konkursmasse herausgekauft.
Von der Community, das heißt, die haben gesagt, wenn der und der Betrag aufgebracht wird, dann wird die Software komplett frei. Und so ist es dann auch gekommen. Also da gibt es verschiedenste Motivationen. Es ist nicht unbedingt jetzt immer nur der Konkurs und dass irgendwas total schlecht läuft. Manchmal sieht man halt auch einfach ein, dass das Open Source Modell den großen Vorteil hat, dass es zu mehr Akzeptanz führt. Also auch große Firmen wie Apple zum Beispiel machen das. Also ihr HTML-Renderer, das was quasi die Grundlage für Browsing und für diverse andere Sachen sind, das ist halt auch Open Source. Und jetzt fließt das eben dann auch bei anderen Firmen mit in die Produkte ein, wie zum Beispiel Nokia. Und das ist für sie natürlich auch von Vorteil, weil sie dadurch natürlich indirekt die Standards setzen, obwohl sie eigentlich erstmal weniger Kontrolle ausüben.
Wo ist der Punkt, wo die Open Source Entwickler dann auch sagen, Moment mal, jetzt reicht es uns, aber wir machen hier die ganzen hübschen Sachen und Apple verhökert das und wir verdienen da nichts dran?
Das war dann eher so eine Frage der Motivation auch. Also ein ganz wichtiges Kernelement, warum mach ich sowas? Die allermeisten Projekte im freien Softwareumfeld, die sind ja von Entwicklern entwickelt worden, weil sie selber mal irgendwie das Bedürfnis hatten nach einer bestimmten Funktionalität. Ja, also was weiß ich, mir fehlt irgendeine bestimmte Funktion in einem Programm, was ich zum Sortieren meiner Fotos oder zu was auch immer das jetzt für ein Grund sein mag. Und weil ich eben Software entwickeln kann, fange ich eben mal an, irgendwie was zusammenzuhacken, was mir eben so meine Funktion erfüllt. Und ich mach das ja primär eben um ein Problem, das ich habe, zu lösen. Und andere Leute finden sich dann vielleicht ein, die ein ähnliches Problem haben, die es dann auch damit lösen können und so weiter. Aber es ist ja dann nicht primär ein Profitinteresse, sondern es ist ein Eigeninteresse an dem Programm. Und jetzt sozusagen freie Software zu entwickeln und sich dann später darüber zu ärgern, dass sie irgendwie kommerziell eingesetzt wird, das muss man sich halt irgendwie vorher überlegen. Also entweder ich mach freie Software, dann muss sie von jedem irgendwie nutzbar sein. Oder ich mach eben keine freie Software und will irgendwie sozusagen ein restriktives Modell fahren.
Kommerzielle Aktivität ist ja auch nicht per se schlechtes. Auch wenn man, sagen wir mal, in Ländern, die sonst wirtschaftlich überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit hätten, sich über finanzielle Aktionen, also Stichwort Afrika zum Beispiel, dort feiert ja Linux gerade ein großes Auferstehen. Aber das überhaupt erstmal eine Grundlage für ein wirtschaftliches Aufsteigen ermöglicht. Und insofern kann man da eben mit freier Software doch auch aktiv dazu beitragen. Letztlich hängt es natürlich auch von der Lizenz ab.
Chaosradio 114, es geht um...
Pavel, worum ging es heute noch mal?
Tim, guck mein Internet, worum geht es heute noch mal?
Also hier steht Software Projektmanagement, aber wir haben noch kein Wort zu Software Projektmanagement, aber wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns.
Wir nähern uns, wir brauchen erst mal ein Projekt.
Oh, ey, wenn ich jetzt Konfetti in der Tasche hätte, ich würd's werfen.
Gut, also wir reden über Software und über Softwareentwicklung. Ja, siehst du, das ist die Herangehensweise eines Nicht-Software-Entwicklers.
Der denkt erst über ein Projekt und über Management nach, und gegen Softwareentwicklung geht's doch um Software-Projekt-Management.
Ja, aber um das durchzuführen, muss man halt überhaupt erst mal Softwareentwicklung verstehen und die Motivation der Programmierer verstehen. Und das ist häufig ein Grund, warum eben Projekte auch überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren, weil da viel zu mechanisch rangegangen wird.
Von so Leuten wie mir. Das ist jetzt in Haralds Verständnis meiner.
Na, sagen wir mal so mit deinem Ansatz, dass wir jetzt erst mal mit Softwareprojektmanagement anfangen müssen, bevor wir überhaupt über die Software...
Also erst mal ist es vielleicht so, dass Softwareentwicklung vermutlich mit keiner anderen Tätigkeit zu vergleichen ist. Man versucht immer so Analogien herzustellen mit anderen Ingenieurstätigkeiten zum Beispiel. Es gibt sicherlich auch eine, wie sagen wir mal, Ingenieurs-mäßige Komponente, die gehört dazu. Es gibt eine mathematisch-wissenschaftliche Komponente in der Softwareentwicklung. Und es gibt natürlich die künstlerische Komponente, die kreative Komponente. Und all die greifen ineinander und je nach Projekt hat die eine oder andere, liegt der Schwerpunkt drauf. Und viele Fehler kommen aber auch daher, dass man versucht, dann ein Softwareprojekt in nur eine dieser Schubladen zu stecken und ausschließlich Werkzeuge für diese eine Schublade zur Anwendung bringt und entweder den wissenschaftlichen Teil, den Forschungsaspekt vernachlässigt oder halt das künstlerische Kreative unterdrückt.
Wie ist es aus deiner Erfahrung? Also welche Schublade ist die größte? Also für mich als komplett Außenstehender, ich sag immer Kunst ist das, was ich nicht selbst kann. Also ich würde grundsätzlich sagen, es ist in erster Linie Kunst, was da geschaffen wird. Und der Rest ist nur Zuarbeit. Ist das so oder bildlich ist das so eine romantische?
Nee, auch ein Künstler, auch ein Bildhauer, ein Maler muss natürlich erst mal seine Werkzeuge beherrschen. Technik. Es gehört halt auch Technik und Fertigkeit und Beherrschung seiner Handwerkszeuge und Wissen, Verankerung in der in der Historie, auch Erfahrung. Also da kommt sehr viel zusammen. Und ich würde einfach sagen, dass das auch von der Art des Projekts und dem der Zweck der Software abhängt. Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand zum Beispiel für Versicherungen, also Software für Versicherungen oder Banken entwickelt, Anwendungssoftware und dort primär den künstlerischen Anspruch dann dort Geltung verschafft. Also das glaube ich eher eher nicht. Während je medialer, je grafischer es wird, je fühlbarer und sichtbarer die Resultate sind. Auf der einen Seite umso wichtiger ist auch die Kunst. Oder je esoterischer vielleicht die Aufgabe ist, die man löst, je abstrakter und verrückter das Ganze ist, umso mehr spielt die Kreativität eine Rolle.
Hallo, hier TSU. Mann von Tomtel. Ich bin ganz stolz, dass ich endlich da spielen darf, wo die Rolling Stones Fans schon halb Berlin auseinandergenommen haben, nämlich die Waldbühne, das Bellinova Open Air, diesmal knackig an einem Tag. Wir sind Helden eines der wenigen Deutschlandkonzerte dieses Jahr.
Fritz präsentiert Berlinova mit Tomte, Jimmy Eadworld, den Baby Shambles und Wir sind Helden.
Berlinova Am 2.
September in der Reitbühne. Berlinova in Berlin und im Radio.
Die israelische Armee hat ihre Offensive auf den Norden des Gaza-Streifens ausgedehnt, nach Agenturangaben wurden Panzer und Kampfhubschrauber eingesetzt. Bewaffnete Palästinense erwarteten hinter Schutzwellen den Einsatz israelischer Bodentruppen. In der vergangenen Nacht war die Armee in den Gaza-Streifen eingedrungen, um die Freilassung eines 19-jährigen Soldaten zu erzwingen. Elf sunnitische Rebellengruppen im Irak haben den US-Streitkräften einen Waffenstillstand angeboten. Sie würden die Angriffe einstellen, wenn alle ausländischen Truppen das Land innerhalb von zwei Jahren verließen. Die irakische Regierung und US-Präsident Bush sollten einen Zeitplan für den Abzug der Besatzungstruppen vorlegen. Der irakische Ministerpräsident Al Maliki wies die Forderung nicht direkt zurück. Er könne jedoch nicht sagen, wann die irakischen Soldaten bereit seien, die Verantwortung für die Sicherheit im Land zu übernehmen. Nach der Entdeckung der beiden Mädchen-Leichen im belgischen Liesch hat Ministerpräsident Verhofstadt den Angehörigen die Hilfe des Staates zugesichert. Die Suche nach dem oder den Mördern habe absolute Priorität, sagte Verhofstadt in einer Fernsehansprache. Die seit 19 Tagen vermissten Geschwister wurden von der Polizei unter Kanaldeckeln an einem Bahndamm entdeckt. Nach insgesamt vier Fällen von vermissten Patienten verschärften die Berliner Krankenhäuser ihre Sicherheitssysteme. Wie die Berliner Zeitung berichtet, sollen in den Vivantes Kliniken Demenzkranke mit elektronischen Armbändern ausgestattet werden. Die Klinikleitung setzte dafür aber die Einbildung der Patienten voraus. Außerdem sollen Bewegungsmelder im Bereich installiert werden, die nur vom Personal betreten werden dürfen.
Das erste Viertelfinale zwischen Deutsch, das er...
Das sollte doch nicht kommen. Bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft gibt es heute und morgen erstmals keine Spiele. Nach der zum Teil heftigen Kritik an den Schiedsrichtern hat die dafür zuständige FIFA-Kommission die Unparteiischen für die Viertelfinalspiele benannt. Jörg Tegelhütter, jetzt Dafa.
Das erste Viertelfinale zwischen Deutschland und Argentinien am kommenden Freitag pfeift Luba Schmichel. Der Slowake hatte zuletzt das Achtelfinale zwischen Brasilien und Ghana geleitet. Der deutsche Schiedsrichter Markus Merck wurde für die Runde der besten acht Mannschaften nicht berücksichtigt, kann sich aber weiter Hoffnungen auf einen WM-Einsatz machen. Die heftig kritisierten Graham Paul aus England und Valentin Ivanov aus Russland werden hingegen nach Hause geschickt. Paul hatte dem Kroaten Simonic dreimal gelb gezeigt. Ivanov das Skandalspiel zwischen Portugal und den Niederlanden gepfiffen.
Heute Nacht ist es zunehmend gering bewölkt und trocken bei 15 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab, bei maximal 23 bis 25 Grad. 100 Stadtring Berlin Wilmersdorf Richtung Wedding. Zwischen Hohenzollern-Damm und Spandauer-Damm gibt es in Standhaltungsarbeiten. Dort ist der linken Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, vier Minuten nach halb elf.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Jetzt gleich ist es zu Ende.
Für alle, die nicht Englisch können, sind wir drauf.
Chaosradio 114 habt ihr eingeschaltet. Was war das gerade für ein Hit?
Das war so ein Remix von diesem Kommentar, den der Kanye West nach dieser New Orleans Katastrophe im Fernsehen losgelassen hat. Wie hieß denn auch gleich der andere Vogel?
Mike Myers.
Genau, die beiden standen vor der Kamera und haben so um Spenden gebeten und lalala. Und dann ist den Kanye West total erkrankt geplatzt und hat diesen George Bush doesn't care about black people Spruch abgelassen und es dauerte dann eine Sekunde und die waren auf R und es wurde wieder über Banalitäten geredet. Und dieses Sample hat es natürlich dann gleich in die Musikwelt geschafft und das ist so einer der Remixe, die dabei rausgekommen sind.
Wir haben hier Hörer, die warten noch nicht mal mehr bis wir sagen, ruft mal an 0331 70 97 1.
Die rufen einfach an, die fallen mit der Tür ins Haus, drängen sich gleichsam auf und heißen dann auch noch Sigi.
Ja hallo, ich glaube ich stell mich erstmal vor, ich bin 19, Schüler und programmiere zu Hause als Hobby und in den Firmen auch gegen Geld und ich finde es im Moment ziemlich beschissen wie das ist, weil die meisten Projektmanagementsysteme, CVS, Subversion und Co. die Verlangenheit von mir als Hobbyprogrammierer, dass ich das System nicht nur benutze, sondern auch administriere. Wenn ich aber ein Projekt habe, das vielleicht Monate dauern soll und das wahre und das einzige für mich ist, was ich machen will, dann habe ich keine Lust, mich mit Subversion auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, als würdest du zwei Stunden zu früh anrufen. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich habe nicht die leisteste Ahnung, worum es jetzt gerade hier geht.
Ja, was er anspricht ist halt Projektmanagementsysteme. Also gut, Subversion ist kein Projektmanagementsystem, sondern ein Versionskontrollsystem, also Software, die einem sozusagen das schrittweise voranschreiten in der Softwareentwicklung vereinfacht, indem man halt Änderungen an der Software auch als solche immer wieder abspeichert und jederzeit rückgängig machen kann und transparent machen kann und mit mehreren Leuten gleichzeitig Änderungen am System in einer definierten Form durchführen kann. Subversion ist eins der populäreren, jüngeren Systeme, hat auch einen Vorgänger, das heißt CVS, und das sind eigentlich so die beiden Systeme, die im Wesentlichen im Einsatz sind.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also ich hab mal in irgendeiner Revision einen Scheiß gebaut. 5 Minuten später wollte ich einfach die Revision löschen, ging aber nicht. Weil das Subversion offiziell nicht unterstützt. Im Trick geht das, aber ich find das ziemlich mies. Wenn man das Projektmanagement komplett ansieht, die komplette Verwaltung von dem Ganzen, dann ist es meistens immer noch so, dass trotzdem jeder seinen eigenen Webapp-Server installieren muss. Oder Dabmbank-Server oder was weiß ich immer.
Was ist denn deine Frage? Wolltest du uns jetzt nur erzählen, dass du das Subversion nicht magst? Oder hast du eine konkrete Frage an uns?
Ich wollte das Thema mal aufs Projektmanagement ein bisschen schieben. Ich wollte mich ein bisschen auslassen. Das ist ganz obendrauf ziemlich nervig, weil hier programmiert bei Linux da und da und damit. Und Scheide Tools gibt es trotzdem irgendwo nicht.
Na gut, da bringst du aber jetzt mehrere Sachen zusammen, die unterschiedlich betrachtet werden müssen. Ich meine, irgendwie Werkzeuge. Außerdem finde ich nicht, dass das jetzt Projektmanagementsoftware im eigentlichen Sinne ist. Das ist Software, die einem letzten Endes beim Management auch eine bestimmte Arbeit abnimmt. Aber das ist halt nicht das Management per se.
Also ich muss sagen, Subversion oder CVS, aber Subversion als die modernere Variante sicherlich nicht perfekt. Es gibt eine Menge Dinge, die man daran aussetzen kann. Aber es ist ungefähr 1000 mal besser als kein Versionskontrollsystem. Und ich kann mich noch an Zeiten erinnern, gerade im Softwareentwicklung im Team aus Zeiten, bevor es noch CVS gab. CVS war der größte Segen seiner Zeit bei Softwareentwicklung im Team. Es vereint halt zwei Dinge. Das eine ist die Versionskontrolle. Das heißt, dass man jede Änderung, die man macht, in ein Repository überspielt. Und dann, falls man irgendetwas falsch gemacht hat, eben wieder zurückgehen kann. Das ist die eine Sache. Und CVS und Subversion ermöglichen aber, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig Änderungen an vielen Dateien durchführen. Und im Konfliktfall, wenn zwei Leute widersprüchliche Dinge geändert haben, gibt es eben Mechanismen, die das Ganze auflösen. Ich verstehe übrigens nicht, warum du eine Revision dort ändern wolltest, wenn man halt einfach Mist macht. Achso, du wolltest quasi einfach eine Änderung rückgängig machen und quasi von einem früheren Versionsstand ausgehend arbeiten. Richtig?
Und diesen Bug kannte ich nicht. Und es war jetzt einfach etwas, was nicht in die Historie von dem Projekt reingehört.
Also es gibt immer wieder Probleme und Klinken, aber alles nichts im Vergleich dazu, ohne dieses Netz und doppelten Boden zu arbeiten. Also ich muss sagen, ich kann speziell Subversion eigentlich nur empfehlen, jedem und auch empfehlen, sich damit zu beschäftigen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, sich das anzueignen, wie man das möglichst effizient nutzen kann.
Ja, Sigi, du hast uns jetzt im Prinzip schon mal in die Richtung Tools geschickt, da werden wir auch gleich wieder landen. Danke erstmal dafür. Wir steigen jetzt nochmal ein bisschen weiter vorne ein, damit wir da mal so eine gewisse Linie reinbekommen. Und zwar wollte ich jetzt mal konkret hinterfragen bei Harald, wie das bei dir aussieht in deinem Projekt. Also das Projekt ist im Wesentlichen Netfilter, oder würdest du das noch ein bisschen weiter umspannen oder kleiner definieren?
Wir können jetzt Netfilter nehmen. Also ich bin in einer ganzen Reihe von Projekten involviert, was Voreihe Software betrifft, aber reden wir jetzt einfach mal über das Netfilter Projekt.
Das ist was? Was macht das?
Das ist Firewall-Software für Linux. Also im Prinzip, wenn man eine Firewall, also Netzwerksicherheitsfunktionalität unter Linux realisieren will, dann ist das eben das, was das Linux-Perspektive-System mitbringt. Viele Leute verwenden das, ohne dass sie es wissen, weil es in irgendwelchen DSL-Routern oder sonst irgendwo drin steckt.
Achso, das heißt in meinem Linksys-Gedöns ist das alles wahrscheinlich drin?
Richtig. Ahja.
Also da bin ich ja richtig hui. Sehr flüchtig, erstarrer ich.
Ja endlich mal Holger, das hat ja auch lang genug gedauert.
Nicht vor dir Tim, nicht die vor dir.
Ja und da arbeiten ja relativ viele Leute mit.
Mal mehr, mal weniger. Wie viele sind das? Die Frage ist ja so, dass bei freien Software-Projekten auch die, wie soll ich sagen, die Zugehörigkeit zu einem Projekt sehr frei und sehr lose definiert ist. Also es gibt eben Leute, die schicken mal irgendwie eine kleine Erweiterung ein und verschwinden dann wieder. Dann gibt es Leute, die so mehr oder weniger konstant immer mal hier einen kleinen Bug ausbügeln, da einen anderen Bug ausbügeln. Dann gibt es Leute, die, wie soll ich sagen, schon die Architektur eher mit beeinflussen, die eine eher dauerhafte Verbindung zu dem Projekt auch haben. Die kann aber dann auch von einem Tag auf dem anderen mal irgendwie abbrechen, weil die Leute irgendwie, was weiß ich, was ganz anderes jetzt machen, einen neuen Job haben, ihre Interessen sich geändert haben und so weiter. Das ist alles sehr diffus, sehr, man könnte auch sagen chaotisch, wenn wir schon beim Chaosradio sind.
Wollte ich mal sagen, hat jemand den Hut auf?
Ja, gibt's. Also es ist so, dass in diesem Projekt es ein sogenanntes Chorteam gibt, das ist eine Gruppe von, naja, auch die Zahl der Gruppen, der Mitglieder ändert sich, aber im Moment so fünf, Entwicklern, die sich halt mit dem Projekt irgendwie schon auf lange Zeit beschäftigt haben, die sich dem Projekt entsprechend verbunden fühlen und die sozusagen das Ganze ein bisschen in die Hand nehmen.
Wie wird man da Mitglied in dem Chorteam?
Auf Einladung.
Vom Chorteam?
Genau, vom Chorteam. Das heißt, es gab halt am Anfang mal denjenigen, der es gestartet hat, das ist Paul Rusty Russell aus Australien, und der hat alleine eben Software geschrieben und dann gab es andere Leute, die angefangen haben mitzumachen, die sehr intensiv mitgemacht haben, und dann hat er gemeint, na ja, das werden wir von seiner Person entkoppeln, es wird ein Chorteam gegründet, und dann sind da ein, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Leute dazugekommen im Laufe der Jahre.
Aber es gibt ja auch Gruppen, die machen das richtig mit einer Wahl.
Gibt's auch. Also es gibt da ganz unterschiedliche Kulturen. Also es ist eben so, dass jedes Projekt jetzt, sowohl in freier Software als auch in der kommerziellen Welt, wird man sehen, es gibt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, das zu organisieren, das zu strukturieren. Es gibt Projekte, die unglaublich demokratisch sind. Da könnte man zum Beispiel jetzt das Devium Projekt sich anschauen. Da geht's also um eine freie Linux Distribution. Und da gibt's Wahlen und Wahlausschüsse und was weiß ich was alles. Also es ist so richtig irgendwie mit einem, mit einer ja Constitution eigentlich schon fast. Also eben eine Art Verfassung für das Projekt, wo also die ganzen Regeln definiert sind und so weiter.
Bisschen kleiner Staat, nicht?
Richtig. Und auch mit dem ganzen Overhead, der halt dann dadurch irgendwie erzeugt wird. Also solche, ja Demokratie ist teuer. Ja, ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, dass Demokratie ein falsches Modell ist, weder in der Softwareentwicklung noch im Staat. Aber es ist halt was, was unglaublich viel ja Verwaltung mit sich bringt.
Ist es nur teuer oder ist es auch ineffizient?
Es kommt darauf an, also ich bin schon so ein bisschen der Vertreter, der nahtim hatte da vorhin so einen tollen Begriff.
Du meinst die gutmütige Diktatur?
Mehr oder weniger. Ja, die wohlwollende Diktatur. Also ich bin schon ein bisschen ein Vertreter dieser Art von Kategorie. Also es gibt auch im Internet ja so ein bisschen immer mal wieder das Konzept von rough consensus and running code. Also grober Konsens und funktionierender Code, also funktionierender Software. Und also ich bin halt sehr geprägt durch diese Linux Community, also Linux Kernentwicklung Community. Und da ist es halt auch so, dass es keine definierten Strukturen gibt und keine definierten Hierarchien, sondern es ist halt so, Leute, die sind alteingesessen, die machen das lang genug, die haben entsprechend Erfahrung, die sind angesehen. Und wenn ich, wenn ich oder ich jetzt als jemand, der da ja nur an einem ganz kleinen Teil mit bastelt, oder wenn jetzt jemand, der ganz neu ist in diesem Entwicklungsmodell zum Beispiel ankommt und jetzt eine fundamentale Änderung haben will, dann muss er halt versuchen, die zu verteidigen. Das heißt, er geht auf die Meldungliste, er begründet, warum er das jetzt unbedingt anders machen muss, oder wo der Vorteile liegen. Und er muss halt versuchen, die Leute, die eigentlich Ahnung davon haben, zu überzeugen, dass sozusagen der neue Weg jetzt der bessere ist. Und letztendlich ist es aber kein demokratischer Entscheidungsprozess, sondern es sind halt die Leute, die die Arbeit machen, die diese Maintenance, also die Verwaltung, die Pflege der Software im Wesentlichen tun auf freiwilliger Basis, die entscheiden dann auch, welche Änderungen aufgenommen werden oder nicht.
Wie ist es jetzt bei euch konkret in der Netfilter-Core-Group? Wie werden da Entscheidungen getroffen, wenn kein Konsens hergestellt werden kann?
Ich nehme an, du gehörst zum Core-Team.
Im Core-Team haben wir eigentlich, muss ich sagen, noch nie so wirkliche Konflikte bezüglich der Richtung oder also Konsens-Schwierigkeiten gehabt. Also es ist halt auch so, wenn man so eine Gruppe von Leuten ist, die mit einer bestimmten Software oder Technologie eine lange Zeit arbeiten, diesen gewissen, den gleichen Mindset haben, dann hat man so ein bisschen das Gefühl für the right thing, also in Anführungszeichen, ja? Das ist einfach irgendwie, das hat Ästhetik, das ist rund, das ist strukturiert, das ist so der Weg, in den man gehen will.
Naja, und alle, die nicht mitgehen wollen, die gehen auch vorher weg wahrscheinlich, ne? Also es bleiben dann irgendwann nur noch die übrig, die sowieso einer Meinung sind. Oder zumindest im Ansatz.
Würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen. Also es gibt sicherlich, also ich muss jetzt sagen, aus dem Netfilter Projekt, wir haben da nicht so wahnsinnig viele Konflikte, aber es gibt sicherlich kontroverse Debatten in anderen Projekten, die ich auch mitbekomme, aber bei uns ist es nicht so. Ich würde mal sagen Größenordnung, da kann ich jetzt schwer, habe ich nicht im Kopf die Zahlen.
Ich stelle mal eine Boulevardfrage zu dir. Wie viel Zeitaufwand ist das für dich?
Also ich kann das schwer ausdrücken, es ist auch eben wieder Arbeitsweise. Wenn ich das irgendwie mache aus Enthusiasmus, aus Begeisterung dafür, dann schreibe ich nicht irgendwie eine Stundenliste. Dadurch, dass ich in zahlreiche Softwareprojekte involviert bin, ich lese halt meine E-Mails, ich schaue, was da irgendwie reinkommt, ich bearbeite die, aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich habe jetzt so und so viel Prozent meiner Arbeitszeit für dieses Projekt irgendwie aufgewendet.
Du gehst noch einen bürgerlichen Beruf nach.
Das ist richtig, ja. Also ich mache Softwareentwicklung als Projekt, als Dienstleistung für Firmen. Da schreibe ich auch Stunden auf.
Ist dann der Rest, also ich sage mal, die übrige Softwareentwicklung, für die du keine Stunden schreibst, ist das dann deine komplette Freizeit oder ist das die Hälfte deiner Freizeit? Einfach nur so eine Größenordnung.
Also das Netfilterprojekt, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, nimmt bei mir nicht mehr als ein Viertel meiner Freizeit oder so ein. Das wäre schon die Obergrenze. Ja sicher, es gibt Leute, die sehr viel involvierter mit einem Projekt sind. Mein Problem ist halt, dass ich mich immer für zu viele Dinge begeistert. Also der Chaos Computer Club, da bin ich ja auch aktiv. Chaos Radio hier beispielsweise. Ich habe das Netfilterprojekt, ich arbeite an Linux für Mobiltelefone. Ich arbeite an freier Software zum Auslesen von biometrischen Ausweisen, für LFID, für was weiß ich was. Und man muss das halt dann alles schön aufteilen.
Was ist das? Ist das Hobby?
Äh, Berufung.
Berufung? Das ist dein Leben gleichsam? Harald, wenn das Berufung ist, also wenn das praktisch dein Leben ist, heißt das gleichzeitig, dass man das auch nur machen kann, wenn man es lebt? Also kann man nur erfolgreich Software entwickeln, zumindest in so einer freien Umgebung oder in so einer Open Source Umgebung, wenn man da auch wirklich eher quasi drin als Nerd dranhängt?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen. Also es gibt durchaus Leute, die das wie soll ich sagen, eher funktional als religiös betreiben. Das heißt Leute, die einfach irgendwie an einer bestimmten Software eben maßgeblich mitentwickeln oder überhaupt nur mitentwickeln, weil sie halt jetzt an dieser spezifische technische Problem besonders interessant finden oder weil sie da jetzt gerade einen besonderen Bedarf haben in dieser Richtung oder wie auch immer. Aber für mich ist es eben schon so diese ganze ideologische Komponente von freier Software, also eben Software für bestimmte Anwendungsfälle so gestalten zu können, wie man selber denkt, dass dieses Problem irgendwie gut gelöst ist. Und auch beweisen zu können, dass man zum Beispiel Dinge effizienter kann als andere Software. Also so Dinge einfach, das sind so Motivationskriterien, die da eine Rolle spielen. Und ich bin halt sehr überzeugt von dieser ganzen Ideologie. Also von daher bin ich da schon ein bisschen tief drin.
Was sind denn die kritischen Momente? Also ich könnte mir einerseits vorstellen, dass es halt, ich meine jetzt hast du ja gesagt, ihr habt nicht so viele Konsensprobleme, aber sicherlich gibt es doch schon mal auch unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber, wohin die Reise gehen soll oder irgendeiner dreht mal frei oder macht nicht das, was er mal zugesagt hat und andere Sachen hängen damit. Wie geht man denn damit um?
Also ich beziehe das jetzt mal so ein bisschen allgemein in den Linux Kernel hinein, weil dort es deutlich mehr Konflikte gibt als jetzt speziell im Netfilter-Teil. Und das kriege ich ja auch alles gut mit dort. Und der Linux Kernel selber hat eine unglaublich, wie soll ich sagen, harte, asoziale Diskussionskultur, die Entwicklungsgemeinde dort. Also das ist wirklich jemand, der mal versucht, diese Hauptentwicklungs-Mainliste, die heißt eben Linux Kernel, zu verfolgen. Ich meine, erstens ist unglaublich viel Zeug, unglaublich technisch usw. Aber so die Art und Weise, wie Menschen da untereinander, also miteinander umgehen und wie hart da irgendwie Argumente ausgetragen werden usw. das ist schon irgendwie ziemlich heftig. Und es ist auch mit Sicherheiten, wie soll ich sagen, wenn jemand jetzt nicht so selbstbewusst auftreten kann und seine Version jetzt der Änderung dort vertreten und verteidigen kann, dann gehen da denke ich auch wertvolle Beiträge verloren. Weil jemand schickt das einfach ein, wenn irgendjemand Antwort darauf sagt, ja, was ist denn das für ein Mist und das ist irgendwie hier und da und da passt es nicht usw. usw. Und dann verliert derjenige, der es ursprünglich eingeschickt hat, halt wieder die Lust, weil er sagt, na ja toll, ich möchte jetzt da was dazu beitragen und die behandeln mich irgendwie wie einen letzten Depp, verliert dann die Lust. Hingegen hätte er vielleicht irgendwie ein, zwei, drei Änderungen gemacht und das nochmal eingeschickt, dann wären die Leute vielleicht irgendwie damit zufrieden gewesen und das hätte integriert werden können und alle hätten davon profitiert.
Ist das Arroganz oder ist das...
Ja, also es gibt schon so ein bisschen so diese Arroganz, gerade bei so sehr technischen wie haben wir Hacker entwickelt oder so, kann ich schon sagen, dass es da eine gewisse Arroganz gibt, die wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen oft entsteht aus der Frustration, dass da jetzt so viele Leute irgendwie mitmachen wollen und so viele Leute irgendwie so viele Dinge dazu beitragen wollen und man ja selber vielleicht irgendwie ein ganz anderes Bild hat, wohin man die Software bringen will und man selber so viel mehr Erfahrung hat vielleicht wie auch immer, aber es gibt schon eine ganze Reihe Entwickler speziell in diesem Linux Kernel Umfeld, die da mal ein bisschen irgendwie übers Ziel hinausschießen und es ist traurig eigentlich.
Und gibt es bei dem Linux Kernel Team auch so ein Core Team, was die Entscheidung dann fällt oder wie kommt dann diese Entscheidung dann überhaupt zustande, ob irgendetwas getan werden soll oder nicht?
Linux Kernel ist eigentlich sehr hierarchisch. Also extrem hierarchisch. Das heißt, es gibt eben Linus Torwald selber, der so irgendwie über das Ganze drüber guckt. Da gibt es noch ein, zwei Leutchen, die ihm so an der Seite stehen mit der sogenannten Kernel Maintenance. Und dann gibt es für die einzelnen Subsysteme, nennt man das im Kernel, also Software Teile, gibt es dann sogenannte Maintainer. Also es gibt einen Maintainer, der kümmert sich um alles, was mit Netzwerk zu tun hat, zum Beispiel das David Miller. Das ist sozusagen mein Vorgesetzter, in Anführungszeichen. Und ich bin dann der Maintainer für alles, was mit Netfilter zu tun hat, was wieder ein Unterteil vom Netzwerk ist. Und wenn jetzt jemand eine Änderung in den Netfilter-Teil reinhaben will und der schickt die an Linus Torwald, dann wird er die halt mir schicken. Weil der sagt, naja, mit Netfilter habe ich nichts am Hut, da gibt es halt den, der kennt sich damit aus, der macht das, der soll irgendwie gucken, ob das irgendwie in Ordnung ist. Und letztendlich liegt es dann halt in meiner oder respektive in der Hand des Netfilter-Core-Teams, da dann darüber zu entscheiden. Ich muss das dann, wenn ich die Änderung nach oben darauf agieren will, muss ich die sozusagen an David Miller schicken. Der etikettiert das dann in den Netzwerk-Stack und der schickt dann wieder die geänderten Sachen sozusagen an Linus weiter. Also es ist ein unglaublich...
Also diese ganze Vision und romantische Anarchie-Bild der freien Softwaregemeinde, das ist alles Quatsch.
Na ja, es ist ja nur der Linux-Colon. Also es gibt Projekte, die haben eine ganz andere Kultur.
Was würde dir da einfallen?
Also ein Projekt in ähnlicher Größe, mit ähnlicher Komplexität, in dem es komplett anarchisch zugeht, ist mir nicht bekannt. Da fällt mir kein Beispiel an. Eher in kleineren Projekten dann. Also kann ich dir jetzt mit keinem Beispiel...
Stellen deine Vorgesetzten dich in Frage? Oder ist das so richtig so, okay wir vertrauen im Harald, wenn da jetzt was kommt, dann ist das okay?
Weitestgehend ja. Das kommt natürlich auch darauf an, wie lange man das macht. Also ich mach das jetzt auch schon so 4 Jahre, 5 Jahre rum mit dem Netfilterzeug. Und ja, also es kommt schon hin und wieder mal vor, dass ich irgendwas einschicke, wo David Miller sagt, naja, das ist jetzt aber ein bisschen irgendwie zu viel Änderung für eine neue Kernversion, weil man kann ja nicht irgendwie sozusagen alles umschreiben von einer Release auf die nächste oder zu konservate Dinge irgendwie ändern. Aber im Allgemeinen ist man dann ein eingespieltes Team über die Jahre hinweg.
Der Chat fragt, ob du auch Wert darauf legst, dass die Leute auch körperlich fit sind, die mitpurgieren.
Ich?
Ich bin ja selber nicht körperlich fit, wieso sollte ich da irgendwie Wert drauf legen? Also ich als Antisportler hoch drei.
Also du bist aus der Sport-Mord-Fraktion, ja?
Ja, ganz eindeutig.
Und warum sieht der dann so aus? Na ja gut, wir verdreschen den jetzt einfach.
Keine Zeit zum Essen.
Ist der Sender, den ihr hört, Chaosradio 114, heute am letzten Mittwoch im Monat Software Projektmanagement unser Thema? Wir sind natürlich eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110.
Genau und interessieren würde uns vor allem, wenn ihr selber Softwareprojekte leitet oder in irgendeiner Form, also entweder Open Source oder auch nicht Open Source, also sei es in einer Firma oder mit irgendeiner privaten Gruppe auch oder eben auch als Open Source Projekt als richtiges. Und wenn ihr da Erfahrungen gesammelt habt, die ihr vielleicht mit uns teilen wollt. Gerade so im Hinblick auf das, worüber wir eben gerade gesprochen haben. Also wie ist das mit der Motivation in der Gruppe? Wie führt man zur Entscheidung? Generell, wie läuft die Kommunikation überhaupt? Was ich jetzt auch mal hinterfragen wollte. Also was ist denn eigentlich das Kommunikationsmittel eurer Wahl? Ist das die Mailing-Liste ausschließlich?
Läuft das über Mail? Also ich denke, wir sind da sehr typisch für, für was im freien Softwarebereich passiert. Die typische Kommunikationsstruktur eines freien Softwareprojekts sieht aus, dass einfach alles über Mailing-Listen diskutiert wird. Manchmal gibt es vereinzelt auch Projekte, die im Internet Relay-Chat, im IRC, vielleicht zu festgesetzten Zeiten mal irgendwie chatten oder so. Das hatten wir auch mal angedacht oder angefangen bei Netfilters, da nach zwei, drei Monaten wieder eingeschlafen, weil es niemand so wirklich irgendwie genutzt hat. Es ist halt einfach so, dass bei freien Softwareprojekten auch Leute erstens über den Globus verteilt sind, weltweit daran mitarbeiten, zweitens sehr viele Leute es in ihrer Freizeit tun. Die Freizeit ist halt mal da, mal waren anders. Also es sind keine festgelegten Zeiten. Und dann sich auf ein Kommunikationsmedium zu einigen, was sozusagen synchron arbeitet. Also jetzt Telefonie, irgendwelche Konferenzen, sei Video oder irgendwie Live-Chat oder sonst was. Da müssten ja alle Leute, die was dazu beizutragen haben, irgendwie zur gleichen Zeit teilnehmen können. Und das ist schon irgendwie ein großes Problem.
Ja, da haben wir es natürlich in der Firma viel einfacher, weil die Leute qua Arbeitsvertrag sich alle zu einer festen Zeit, bei uns sind es 10 Uhr morgens, eben an einem Ort versammeln. Und da läuft tatsächlich die meiste Abstimmung einfach direkt im persönlichen Gespräch, entweder beim morgendlichen Stand-up-Meeting oder wenn man an spezifischen Problemen sitzt, in denen man sich gemeinsam vor den Rechner setzt oder einfach spontan kleine Gruppen bildet von den Leuten, die zu dem Problem irgendwie eine Meinung haben oder was beizutragen haben und dann eine Lösung finden.
Was entwickelt ihr? Kennen wir da ein prominentes Beispiel?
Na, es ist nichts, was jetzt als Produkt bislang draußen zu sehen ist. Was man vielleicht sieht, also wir machen überwiegend mediale Installationen, das heißt Multimedia Software, die irgendwo große Bildschirme steuert und die 3D Szenerien rendert, Audio, Video wiedergibt, ein bisschen in den Spielebereich auch hinein ragt das Ganze. Also wir sagen moderne Multimedia Software.
Man muss auch noch dazu sagen, dass wir zum ähnlichen Thema schon mal ein Chaosradio Express Podcast gemacht haben, für die von euch, die das nicht verfolgen. Vielleicht schaut ihr auch noch mal rein bei Chaosradio Express 28, da haben wir dann das Thema Extreme Programming im Detail noch mal auseinander gewälzt, weil das ist eine Methode, die ihr bei euch in der Firma anwendet. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal so kurz zusammenfassen, was sich dahinter verbirgt, weil das ja für eure Methodik auch ganz entscheidend ist.
Ja, also wir haben vor jetzt fünf Jahren damit begonnen und ja, am besten hört man sich irgendwann speziell zu Extreme Programming, was wissen wir tatsächlich die Sendung an, aber vielleicht ganz, ganz eine kurze Definition davon. Also Extreme Programming ist heißt deswegen extrem, weil das ist ich sehe gerade dieses Mischpult. Wenn jetzt auf deinem Mischpult alle guten Praktiken, von denen man weiß, wie zum Beispiel Code Reviews sind gut, Testen ist gut, kurze Iterationszyklen sind gut und, und, und. Dass man halt in kurzer Zeit, dass man halt nicht monatelang da sitzt und an den Dingen herumwurschtelt, sondern eben eine Veränderung macht, schnell wieder ein funktionierendes System hat und eben sich in kleinen Schritten zum Ziel hangelt. Also jedenfalls, wenn man all diese guten Ideen nimmt und jetzt würde man mit dem Regler auf dem Mischpult regeln, so von dieser guten Idee nehme ich jetzt null Prozent oder ich schiebe halt den Regler hoch, dann ist bei Extreme Programming sind alle Regler auf Anschlag gestellt. Das heißt, praktisch heißt es, wenn Code Reviews gut sind, heißt das, man macht ständig Code Reviews, das heißt, man verbringt gar nicht Zeit alleine vor dem Rechner, sondern sitzt eben immer zu zweit vor dem Rechner beim sogenannten Pair Programming, so nach dem Vier-Augen-Prinzip.
Okay, also man macht von allem Richtigen immer das Meiste. Warum macht man es nicht immer so? Also warum kriegt das Kind den Namen Extreme Programming und man sagt nicht einfach, das ist jetzt Programming und alles andere ist Mumpitz?
Na ja, es gibt, also man kann es tatsächlich nicht immer so machen. Es eignet sich auch nicht für alle Arten von Projekten und es hat schon einen bestimmten Einschlag. Aber ich zähle vielleicht nochmal ein paar Merkmale auf. Also Testen beispielsweise, man schreibt beim Extreme Programming zuerst die Tests, Modultests und eigentlich darf es in einem Projekt nach Extreme Programming keine Zeile geben zu der oder keine Funktion geben, zu der nicht auch ein entsprechender Test existiert, der dann automatisch ausgeführt wird. Dann bei der, also Extreme Programming gehört auch zu den sogenannten agilen Methoden. Das heißt, man versucht sich nicht mit tausendseitigen Pflichtenheften oder vorneweg zu belasten, sondern erkennt an, dass man eigentlich erst im Prozess des Umsetzens das Problem wirklich versteht und begreift. Und daher versucht man auch Dokumentation nur so viel wie unbedingt notwendig und rotwendig und diese auch eng an den Entwicklungsprozess ran zu knüpfen. Dann versucht man möglichst flexibel zu bleiben. Das heißt, man versucht auch ganz am Anfang bereits die Sinnhaftigkeit. Oder wenn man eine Software entwickelt, dann entwickelt man sie zu einem bestimmten Zweck. Das heißt, es gibt normalerweise so etwas wie einen Kunden und man lässt dem Kunden halt möglichst viel Entscheidungsfreiheit und lässt ihn halt auch steuern und lenken und bezieht ihn ein und versucht ihn als Verbündeten zu behandeln und nicht als als Störfaktor.
Dazu muss er aber auch wissen, worüber er spricht.
Ja, da muss man ihn dann eben in die Lage zu versetzen, die letzten Dinge auch zu beurteilen. Das geht am besten anhand eines funktionierenden Systems, weil bevor der Kunde nicht sieht, was er eigentlich bekommt, fällt es sowieso schwer, soweit zu abstrahieren. Das heißt, man hangelt sich eben so von funktionierendem System zu funktionierendem System und sagt dann ganz konkret, ok, so, also auch über Prototypen, beispielsweise der sogenannte Spike Solutions, wo man dann eher von vornherein technische Risiken einzuschätzen.
Was sind denn Spike Solutions?
Spike Solutions sind bestimmte Experimente, die man veranstaltet, um Unsicherheiten auszuräumen. Also geht dieses oder jenes dann, bevor man es wirklich einbaut und realisiert, macht man dann auf ganz eng fokussiert auf ein ganz bestimmtes Problem, versucht man eine Lösung hinzubekommen und um zu sehen, ist das machbar oder nicht und damit eben bestimmte technische Risiken im Vorfeld auszuräumen. Ja, und so gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe anderer Prinzipien, Praktiken, die halt sehr schön beim Extreme Programming ineinander greifen. Das sogenannte Stand-up Meeting, was ich schon erwähnt habe, gehört dazu. Das heißt, wir versammeln uns eben jeden Morgen um 10 vor einer großen Tafel, wo dann im Stehen, damit das Meeting nicht ausufert, weil das ist auch ein sehr gutes Mittel, um zu verhindern, dass Meetings ausufern, wenn alle stehen müssen. Ansonsten redet man sich fest.
Das machen wir jetzt beim Kongressplanung auch.
Wir sind jetzt zwölf Entwickler, allerdings skaliert das Ganze nicht wirklich gut, bis zwölf jetzt in einem Meeting. Wir haben gesehen, eine sehr gute Größe sind so vier bis sechs etwa, ist so die optimale Teamgröße, deswegen haben wir jetzt auch bei den zwölf Leuten drei Teams eingerichtet, die für sich einen Stand-up Meeting machen, allerdings regelmäßig die Teams untereinander wiederum Mitglieder austauschen, um die Kommunikation zwischen den Teams zu befördern. Das ist eine sehr einfache Methode, um Know-how zu transferieren.
Das finde ich wirklich super da dran, weil man ganz häufig das Problem, gerade so bei kleineren Start-up Companies, die wollen halt irgendwie so ein bestimmtes Produkt entwickeln, haben da so eine bestimmte Idee und dann suchen sie sich ihre Programmierer nach bestimmten Fähigkeiten. Wir brauchen einen, der das kann, wir brauchen einen für die Systemadministration, wir brauchen einen für diese Low-Level-Geschichten, dann brauchen wir jemanden, der das GUI macht. Das ist natürlich auch sinnvoll, dass man Leute hat, die auch ein bisschen Erfahrung haben in dem Bereich, was man hat, aber man tendiert dann häufig dazu, eben nur genau diesen einen zu haben für einen bestimmten Bereich. Das führt dann dazu, dass eben diese Leute sich auch wirklich nur um ihre Software kümmern, sich relativ wenig um die anderen Produkte der anderen Leute kümmern. Dann gibt es dann immer so Streit, so warum läuft das nicht? Na ja, deine Software ist schuld, meine Software ist schuld. Solche Sachen. Und wenn die Leute dann mal krank sind oder einfach nur demotiviert sind, dann fehlt es natürlich an allen Ecken und Enden von Stilfragen, mal ganz abgesehen im Code.
Und bei uns haben wir zum Beispiel, als auch ein Teil von Extreme Programming, ein kollektives Code Eigentum, Collective Code Ownership. Das heißt, jeder darf jederzeit überall Änderungen durchführen, ohne Rücksprache mit irgendjemandem halten zu müssen. Das ist deswegen auch möglich, weil es diese ganzen Tests gibt, die automatisch ablaufen. Das heißt, es gibt auch eine gewisse Sicherheit, dass durch Änderungen, die jemand macht, er selbst wenn er nicht so erfahren ist oder die Auswirkungen vielleicht nicht ganz abschätzen kann, eben nichts kaputt machen kann, ohne dass es durch Tests abgefunden wird.
Na ja, dass einerseits jeder überall, jederzeit ändern kann und ja auch generell dazu ermutigt wird, dies zu tun. Die Tests sind ja sozusagen die Leser, die permanent über alle Änderungen rübergehen und dann schon auch inkonsistenten, ob das nun immer so funktioniert, ist natürlich was anderes. Aber der Ansatz ist natürlich ähnlich. Man hat nicht mehr so diese totale Ownership. Das ist aber mein Quot, den darfst du aber jetzt nicht anfangen.
Witze-Monopol.
Also vielleicht, wir hatten ja vorher noch einen kleinen Seitenabstecher. Ich hatte ja vorher nach der Zahl der Quotzeilen gefragt. Jetzt in Netfilter waren es glaube ich so um die 100.000 Zeilen. C-Code. Das ist jetzt, wie kann man sich 100.000 Zeilen C-Code vorstellen?
Erkläre mal jemandem wie mir, was das bedeutet.
Auf eine DIN A4 Seite passen typischerweise 70 Zeilen etwa. Das heißt...
So ein Pressemitteilungsstil.
Das heißt 7.000 Zeilen halt 100 Seiten, 70.000 Zeilen etwa 1000 Seiten. Das heißt, es ist etwa ein Buch mit 1.500 Seiten etwa. Wobei erschwerend hinzukommt, dass ein einziger Fehler in diesen 1.500 Seiten fatale Folgen haben kann.
Wie dick ist so ein Harry Potter Buch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Dieser Reißer, der Schwarm, den sehr viele gelesen haben, hat glaube ich 800 Seiten gehabt.
So zweimal das. Was jetzt auch noch? Es gibt natürlich ein Programm.
Wie viel sind es denn bei euch?
Bei uns sind die Kern Engine etwa 400.000 Zeilen Code, die wir im Repository haben, die entstanden sind in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren.
Vielleicht ist das die falsche Frage, aber hat irgendjemand darüber den Überblick?
Ja.
Wie behältst du den Überblick über ein 2000-seitiges Buch?
Wie überhält man den Überblick bei der Wikipedia?
Viele Augen. Es ist natürlich hierarchisch strukturiert auch. Es ist eben nicht wie ein normaler Roman, sondern es gibt so etwas wie ein Inhaltsverzeichnis. Es ist eher so, die Teile bauen aufeinander auf.
Das heißt, es hat keinen roten Faden, wie ein normaler Roman ihn hätte.
Genau.
Und es gibt eben Module und Untermodule. Also es ist eben hierarchisch strukturiert. Aber es ist in der Tat eine Komplexität. Und da kommen wir auch schon zu dem Punkt, warum man Teams braucht. Alleine würde man, wenn man alleine 400.000 Zeilen Code schreiben wollte und wirklich extrem gut ist und extrem schnell schreibt. Also ich habe in guten Jahren mal so 30 bis 40.000 Zeilen Code geschrieben. Das ist qualitativ hochwertigen Code. Man kann natürlich pro Jahr. Also 30 bis 40.000 Zeilen. Der Durchschnitt angeblich liegt so bei pro Programmierer bei 6.000 Zeilen Code pro Jahr. Bei Microsoft bei 1000 Zeilen pro Jahr.
Das ist ja dann besonders gut.
Die haben längere Zeilen dort.
Die haben entweder längere Zeilen oder die bzw. die machen das vielleicht besonders sorgfältig, wer weiß. Oder die haben halt diesen großen Loch.
Die Idee, jeder Programmierer macht nur 1000 Zeilen, ist ja grundsätzlich dann schon mal nicht schlecht, weil darüber kann er auf jeden Fall den Überblick behalten, oder nicht?
Na ja, es reicht aber dann nicht, nur über diese 1000 Zeilen den Überblick zu haben, sondern...
Auch was sie bedeuten.
Und was sie bedeuten, wie sie sich ins Gesamtsystem einfügen.
Wer lautet denn dann bei Microsoft den Mist? Weil an irgendeinem Punkt funktioniert es ja nicht mehr. Sonst wären die Produkte nicht so...
Also... Ich mein, ganz so schlecht wie der Ruf ist die Software eigentlich nicht. Mir tun nur die Entwickler teilweise leid. Also wenn man sich den mal anschaut, den Quellcode, das sieht in weiten Strecken schon nach Arbeit für galieren Sträflinge aus. Also das ist wirklich Code. Da würde ich, weiß ich nicht, lieber Zeitungen austragen gehen als...
Warum? Was unterscheidet den Code von einem Code, der nicht für galieren Sträfling ist?
Na ja, beispielsweise, dort besteht der Großteil des Codes darin, Daten von einer höheren Schicht entgegenzunehmen, ein bisschen umzuarrangieren, minimal und an eine tiefere Schicht weiterzuleiten, eventuell noch ein bisschen Fehlerzustände zu prüfen. Aber eigentlich tut der Code nicht wirklich etwas. Also es sind keine anspruchsvollen Algorithmen drin oder der löst nicht unbedingt irgendein Problem, sondern es ist eigentlich nur so Vermittler. Also es ist extrem viel Vermittler-Code, Klebstoff, wenn man so will, der einfach nur die Teile irgendwie zusammenhält, aber selber eigentlich nichts tut oder kaum etwas tut. Und es ist sehr undankbar, solchen Code zu schreiben.
Warum machen die das?
Ja, gut, teilweise hängt das vermutlich auch wieder mit der Organisation der Projekte zusammen. Ich habe mir sagen lassen, ich habe selber in SAP Code noch nicht reingeguckt, aber das ist bei SAP im Prinzip genau dasselbe. Es sind einfach Schichten über Schichten über Schichten, die dort Dinge tun und wo aber einfach nur vor allem Daten hin und her gereicht werden und man eigentlich gar nicht weiß mehr, wo die Funktionalität überhaupt steckt.
Das ist so wie der Witz mit dieser Gruppe von Leuten, die sich auf der Straße versammelt haben und einer kommt dazu und fragst, was die hier losen.
Was man da auch ganz wichtig sehen muss, wenn wir jetzt über Microsoft-Produkte sprechen, dann sind das ja auch immer unglaublich komplexe Software-Produkte, also egal, ob man jetzt eine Textverarbeitung sich anschaut oder mit dem ganzen Funktionsumfang, der da eingebaut ist oder irgendwelche Betriebssysteme. Das sind wirklich verdammt umfangreiche Projekte, wo verdammt viele Leute beschäftigt sind. Und dann kommen wir zum interessanten Punkt, nämlich auch die Qualität und die Skillsets der Entwickler und dessen, was man bereit ist, dafür auszugeben. Und das ist halt in der Softwareentwicklung, zumindest im kommerziellen Bereich, und dem bin ich ja auch angehörig, ist es halt mittlerweile schon so, dass es unglaublich große, wie soll ich sagen, was meintest du vorhin mit den Entwicklern? Zeitungen austragen. Es gibt halt ein paar Leute, die irgendwie das Know-how haben, die vielleicht mal einen Design machen, und dann gibt es ganze Tausendschaften, die irgendwo in Indien oder in China oder sonst irgendwo sitzen, die dann einfach irgendwie so...
Die Galeernsklaven.
Genau, die Galeernsklaven, richtig. Und dann wächst sowas auch über Jahre, über Jahrzehnte, dann hat diese gewachsenen Systeme eine Schicht über der anderen, Kleber dazwischen und so weiter, und dann sowas noch irgendwie zu maintainen, das ist halt das große Problem.
Und das wächst danach erst die Struktur der Firma, die das herstellt selbst, oder wächst die mit? Was bedingt da was? Bedingt die Software die Struktur des Unternehmens?
Also Microsoft hat da viele Dinge ausprobiert. Die meisten sind oder viele Dinge sind gescheitert. Eine Vision, die sie hatten, war die vom sogenannten Metaprogrammierer, der oben an der Spitze sitzt, in dem Fall sollte das Bill Gates sein, der eben ganz oben an der Spitze auf irgendeine Art und Weise Metaprogrammierung macht. Und so ist eine ganze Hierarchie von Programmierern gibt, die dann bis ganz unten die Coder, die dann das in funktionierenden Code umsetzen. Aber das wurde ernsthaft probiert bei Microsoft. Es gibt auch ein paar ganz interessante Bücher dazu. Aber das ist komplett fehlgeschlagen. Das hat einfach nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt ist man irgendwo in der, versucht man so einen Mittelweg, glaube ich, zu gehen. Das ist schon die Leute ein bisschen Verantwortung auch für Module, für Architektur haben und auch die Teams nicht allzu groß werden zu lassen. Wobei das Team, was den Internet Explorer, die Version, waren das die Vierer oder die Fünfer Version, jedenfalls als Microsoft das Internet entdeckt hatte und die Netscape bedrohung hat, hat man tausend Mann angesetzt, die am Internet Explorer...
Tausend?
Tausend.
Das kommt ja selbst mir absurd groß vor. Ist es auch. Wie viele Leute bauen in Firefox? Gibt es da eine Zahl?
Ich glaube, bei Netscape waren zuletzt etwa 100 Leute mit der Browserentwicklung beschäftigt. Und wie viele braucht man wirklich? Ja, ist wahrscheinlich schon eine Größenordnung für den Browser selbst. Ich kenne den Code auch ein bisschen jetzt von Firefox und Netscape. Das ist auch ein recht komplexes Biest und da gibt es viele.
Also ein bisschen mehr als a few good men.
Ja, also vermutlich, wenn ich jetzt einen Wettbewerbsfähigen Browser from the scratch neu schreiben sollte, würde ich wahrscheinlich schon einen 30-50 Mann Team dafür verlangen. Sonst würde ich sagen, das macht keinen Sinn.
Fritz vom RBB 1 nach 12.
Nach dem Einmarsch israelischer Truppen in den Gaza-Streifen hat die Europäische Union die Konfliktparteien zur Mäßigung gemahnt. EU-Außenkommissarin Ferrero-Waldner sagte, beide Seiten müssten einen Schritt zurück machen, um eine unkontrollierbare Krise zu verhindern. Sie forderte, die Palästinenser nachdrücklich auf den verschleppten israelischen Soldaten freizulassen. Von Israel verlangte sie, eine diplomatische Lösung zu ermöglichen. 11 sunnitische Rebellengruppen im Irak haben den US-Streitkäften einen Waffenstillstand angeboten. Sie würden die Angriffe einstellen, wenn alle ausländischen Truppen das Land innerhalb von zwei Jahren verließen. Die irakische Regierung und US-Präsident Bush sollten einen Zeitplan für den Abzug der Besatzungstruppen vorlegen. Der irakische Ministerpräsident Al Maliki wies die Forderungen nicht direkt zurück. Er könne jedoch nicht sagen, wann die irakischen Soldaten bereit seien, die Verantwortung für die Sicherheit im Land zu übernehmen. Mehrere tausend Studentenschüler und Gewerkschafter haben in Wiesbaden und Hamburg gegen Studiengebühren und Verschlechterungen im Bildungsbereich demonstriert. Nach Bayern, Baden-Württemberg, Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen beschloss am Abend Hamburg die Einführung von Semestergebühren ab Sommer 2007. Hessen will ab Herbst 2007 Gebühren erheben. Nach insgesamt vier Fällen von vermissten Patienten verschärfen die Berliner Krankenhäuser ihre Sicherheitssysteme. Wie die Berliner Zeitung berichtet, sollen in den Vivantes Kliniken Demenzkranke mit elektronischen Armbändern ausgestattet werden. Außerdem sollen Bewegungsmelder in Bereichen installiert werden, die nur vom Personal betreten werden dürfen. Bei der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gibt es heute und morgen erstmals keine Spiele. Nach der zum Teil heftigen Kritik an den Schiedsrichtern hat die dafür zuständige FIFA-Kommission die Unpartei schon für die Viertelfinalspiele benannt. Jörg Tegelhütter.
Das erste Viertelfinale zwischen Deutschland und Argentinien am kommenden Freitag pfeift Lubosz Michl. Der Slowake hatte zuletzt das Achtelfinale zwischen Brasilien und Ghana geleitet. Der deutsche Schiedsrichter Markus Merck wurde für die Runde der besten Achtmannschaften nicht berücksichtigt, kann sich aber weiter Hoffnungen auf einen WM-Einsatz machen. Die heftig kritisierten Graham Paul aus England und Valentin Ivanov aus Russland werden hingegen nach Hause geschickt. Paul hatte dem Kroaten Simonic dreimal gelb gezeigt. Ivanov, das Skandalspiel zwischen Portugal und den Niederlanden gepfiffen.
Heute Nacht ist es zunehmend gering bewölkt und trocken bei 15 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab bei maximal 23 bis 25 Grad. Die Landstraße 33 Mannschnur Richtung Hönow ist an der Kreuzung Hönow nach einem schweren Unfall voll gesperrt. Und A100 statt Ring Berlin Wilmersdorf Richtung Wedding zwischen Hohenzollern Damm und Spandauer Damm gibt es in Standhaltungsarbeiten. Dort ist der linke Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, 4 Minuten nach halb 12.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Chaos Radio 114 ist hier immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Gibt es das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club 114. Heute beschäftigt sich mit Software Projektmanagement.
Ja und jetzt machen wir das schon seit so lange. Und wir hatten früher mal so eine tolle Tradition und die müssen wir unbedingt mal wieder einführen. Weil wir reden immer so viel über Technik und es gibt ganz viele Leute, die damit vielleicht überhaupt nichts anfangen können. Und deswegen spielen wir jetzt auch nochmal ein Lied für Marianne, damit sie auch was davon hat.
Was war das?
Das war Kate Bush und zwar Pee. Ein Lied über Pee und sie singt Pee. Ist das auch krank?
Nein, sie singt jede einzelne Ziffer von Pee, also nicht alle, weil da werden wir noch eine Weile mit beschäftigt.
Sie macht überhaupt sehr schöne Nerdmusik. Es gibt auch noch so ein anderes Lied, das heißt Deeper Understanding. Ich glaube, auf ihrem vorletzten Album und da geht es auch so um die Abhängigkeit eines Nerds, der irgendwie vor seinem Rechner sitzt und der Rechner spricht zu ihm, wie I give you love and deeper understanding und alles ganz dramatisch. Kann ich nur schon empfehlen, die Gute. Ja, haben wir eigentlich schon, Holz kein Fußball. Nerds hassen ja Fußball. Ist das schon aufgefallen?
Ich finde, Leute, die Fußball hassen, sind genauso wie Leute, die Weihnachten doof finden.
Oh, ich find beides doof.
Kannst du nicht mal endlich aufhören, Abiturient zu sein?
Ich war noch nie Abiturient, weil ich hab keinen.
Du benimmst dich wie einer. Weihnachten ist doch voll Scheiße, ganz Kommerzscheiße. Also ich find Weihnachten da...
Nö, nicht wegen dem Kommerz.
Sie ist mir weitgehend egal. Aber wenn irgendwo Fußball läuft, sitz ich auch da und denk mir, hier läuft ja Fußball und amüsiere mich. Das ist jetzt nicht so richtig gesteigert und wert drauf, aber ich find's so albern zu sagen. So, ey, total scheiße, ey, ganz, ey, ey.
Ich find's super. Ich hab Spaß. Ne Menge.
Das Einzige, was mich echt abfuckt, sind diese Deppenfähnchen.
Also Deppenfähnchen?
Deppenfähnchen an den...
Ja, oder die Stadiongesänge.
Ne, so farbige Twingus, die mit Stofftieren vollgestopft sind. Und dann so zwei so Deutschlandfähnchen an der Seite haben.
Ja, das ist schon albern, ne?
Und die Besitzerin hat ein Nagelstudio.
Ich hab auch noch was ganz tolles hier. Da wird einem doch warm ums Herz, oder?
Ich dachte das wär die Nationalen.
Das singen die doch immer.
Das ist ein, ja, das ist so ein, so ein, so ein Beiwerk, was man so erwerben kann in diesen Zeiten.
Was hast du dafür bezahlt?
Ich hab das Geschonken gekrochen bekommen. Genau.
Fan-Gesänge sind auch was was tolles. Ich hab, also am schönsten ist der Fan-Gesang, falls es irgendwie noch zu einem Match gegen England kommen sollte. So Football Going Home, den fand ich einfach großartig.
Ja, wie dem auch sei, weil du vielleicht wieder zu sich warst.
Wieso würdest du dazu nicht kommen? Ich meine, guck dir mal Beckham an, den alten Sack. Da kannst du den Beckenbauer gegen antreten lassen. Super, wir haben Chaosradio gehyjacked. Wo waren wir denn eigentlich stehen?
Du wolltest einen Werbeblog einstellen.
Software, Projektmanagement, alte meiner Pflicht.
Wir wollten doch den Werbeblog machen.
Ich leuchte mal den Werbeblog ein.
Was, hast du was zum Anleiten?
Natürlich, ich hab hier so richtig eine Rampe. Herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio 114.
Eigentlich ist unser Thema ja Software, Projektmanagement, aber hier ist die Reklame.
Ja, es gibt eine neue Datenschleuder.
Welche Nummer haben wir denn auf der Datenschleuder? 90 oder so. Die neue Datenschleuder, Nummer 90. Mit tollen Themen.
Das ist ja unglaublich, Tim.
Und du kannst sie sogar umblättern.
Sie hat ganz viele Seiten, die ich umblättern kann, Tim.
Und auf jeder ist sogar ein eigener Barcode aufgedruckt.
Hast du das schon gesehen, Holger? Ein Barcode, das sind ganz viele Striche, wo Nummern drin gespeichert sind.
Das ist ja unglaublich. Nicht wahr?
Und guck dir die Themen an. Blackberry, des J-Tech-Rätsels, Lösung, das will man doch haben, oder?
Das will man haben, Tim.
Piratendemonstrationen, huh, Aktivismus fokussieren.
Sag mal, Tim, gibt es denn vielleicht auch die Rubrik Chaosradio Podcasting?
Oh, ich glaube, die ist auch dabei.
Und schau mal, hier ist sogar was zur FIFA WM.
Ja, also das alles gibt es in der neuen Datenschleuder. Ab jetzt wieder im Abonnement erhältlich. Siehe auch ds.cccde oder www.cccde-ds. Jetzt bin ich schon überfragt. Na, ihr kriegt ja schon raus. 40 Sekunden haben wir noch. Da läuft das Musikfeld aus. Ja, da kann man generell drauf hinweisen. Die Datenschleuder erscheinen viermal im Jahr. Und jetzt ist es gerade mal wieder so weit. Das ist eine ziemlich dicke und gute geworden. Und wenn ihr Interesse habt, könnt ihr das machen. Und es gibt die Datenschleuder auch als PDF-Podcast. Die kommt dann ein bisschen später. Und wer das richtig schön klokompatibel haben will, der kauft sich natürlich das Original.
Das liegt beim STC-Tele-Shop. Das immer wieder.
Rufen sie an, abonnieren sie jetzt.
Sag mal, Paul, was war eigentlich nur mal das Thema?
Tele-Shopping.
Pi, 3,141592653589793238.
Unser Thema ist Softwareentwicklung und Softwareprojektmanagement.
Harald, warum bist du jetzt gerade so, du hast dich gerade so eschoffiert.
Eschoffiert? Na ja, ich fand nur, dass wir eben irgendwann zum Thema mal wieder zurückkehren sollten.
Zum Thema bei Chaosradio, hast du das gehört?
Und vor allem, wenn ihr schon Werbung macht, dann hättet ihr mal erwähnen können, dass man mittlerweile unser komplettes Backlog der Datensteuerer erwerben kann.
Warte.
Ich kann das doch gar nicht.
Es gibt jetzt einmalig eben ausgerechnet ein ausgezeichnetes Sonderangebot. Ein Komplettpaket aller noch auf Lage befindlichen Datenschleudern des Chaos Computer Clubs.
Ja.
Das ist ja irre. Da kann man dann nachlesen, zum Beispiel wie in der Datenschleuder Nummer 14 vom Dezember 1985, die persönliche Daten übertragen wurde von den Beamten durch Tastatureingabeverbot unterbrochen.
Oh, das ist ja spannend. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Tastatureingabeverbot. Ach so. Heute ist der?
Heute ist der 28.
Heute ist der.
28.
Juni.
Er sagt 28. klingelt da nicht irgendwas?
Warte, ich spule mal zurück.
28.?
Ja, so sechs Monate.
Ach so, der 27.. Ja, das wurde auch hier gerade treffen, wieder mal im Chat. Der Chat ist ja mal wieder ganz aufgeweckt.
Entschuldigung, ist das jetzt Reklame?
Ja, das ist immer noch eigentlich Reklame. Genau, weiterhin im Angebot beim Chaos Computer Club. Jetzt neu. 23.
Chaos Communication Kongress.
In nur sechs Monaten. Der 23. Kongress steht vor der Tür. Unmittelbar quasi. Also packt schon mal die Sachen. Und es gibt dazu auch noch kaum Informationen im Web. Aber wir wollten trotzdem schon mal darauf hinweisen. Denn der Kongress wird auch in diesem Jahr wieder stattfinden.
Motto?
Das Motto steht auch schon fest.
Software.
Ich glaube, das Motto ist noch geheim. Ah nein, das Motto heißt Who can you trust? Und das ist unser Thema, um mal alles zu hinterfragen, was heutzutage so auf dem Tisch liegt. Das ist ja eine ganze Menge.
Wem würden Sie vertrauen?
Wenn Sie überhaupt Bescheid wüssten.
Der 23. Chaos Communication Kongress wieder zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, zwischen den Jahren.
Zum Teil müssen wir sogar annehmen, dass junge Leute auch eine Gehirnwäsche unterzogen werden.
Chaosradio 114 ist hier.
Es geht um Software Projektmanagement.
Im Wesentlichen. Haben wir jetzt die Werbung soweit oder fällt uns noch was?
Ich denke wir haben jetzt erstmal genug geworden.
Da bin ich aber froh und der Harald auch.
Außerordentlich, ja.
Jetzt hier erstmal Mahlzeit.
Software Projektmanagement.
Wir werden jetzt auch wieder ganz ernst.
Ja, natürlich. Die Motivation war ja ganz geil. Also Eingangs der Sendung schon mal Kurzthema. Das würde mich dann auch noch interessieren. Was hat euch dazu gebracht, sowohl Harald in der Open Source-Ecke Softwareentwicklung zu betreiben als auch Pawel, das dann beruflich in so einer streng hierarchischen, also in einer Firmen-Ecke zu machen. Wo seid ihr auf die schiefe Bahn gekommen? Ich sitze oft genug vor meinem Rechner und denke mir, verdammter Axt, immer dieser Spam. Schön wäre doch, wenn ich jetzt so einen Button an meinem Mailer hätte, wo ich draufdrücke und dann bounced es und dann werde ich automatisch aus diesen Listen ausgetragen. Aber ich käme im Traum nicht drauf, mich hinzusetzen und sowas zu programmieren. Jetzt mal aus davon, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es geht, was eh nicht geht.
Oder?
Okay, das sind jetzt zwei Fragen auf einmal getarnt.
Du kannst mich so durcheinander bringen.
Getarnt irgendwie als ein geschickter Versuch, aber ich werde trotzdem antworten. Nehmen wir mal das mit dem Spam als erstes. Mit dem Mail-Programm klappt es leider nicht, aber es gibt eine Sache, eine nette Sache, die man gegen Spammer unternehmen kann, die auch ganz gut funktioniert. Da muss man aber seinen eigenen Mail-Server haben und den entsprechend konfigurieren, und zwar sogenannte Tar Pits einrichten. Das heißt, es funktioniert so.
Tar Pit Teergruben.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt so der Mail-Server vom Spammer kommt und versucht, eine Mail zuzustellen, und man identifiziert ihn als Spammer, da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das zu tun, dann sagt man ihm nicht etwa, nö, ich will deine Mail nicht, weil du bist ein Spammer, sondern man lässt ihn erstmal hängen in der Leitung. Solange wie es eben nur geht, so nach Standard. Das heißt, man wartet und wartet und wartet. Und irgendwann, kurz bevor er sagt, nee, ich will die Mail doch nicht. Was dann passiert?
Das ist die gleiche Taktik, wie so Telekommunikationsunternehmen bei ihren Kunden-Hotlines begleiten.
Erst diejenigen, die in die Warteschlange hängen und dann irgendwann, wir nehmen den Andruf jetzt doch nicht entgegen.
Und was dann passiert ist, dass wenn jetzt gerade man einen Mailsaber betreibt, wo auch möglicherweise viele Mails dann hingehen, dass der Mailsaber vom Spammer einfach losläuft und erstmal hängen bleibt. Das heißt, der hängt dort plötzlich und hat offene Verbindungen und kommt eben nicht weiter im Abarbeiten seiner Liste, weil man ihn eben einfach aufhält. Und weil das natürlich die Produktivität der Spamversender behindert, durchforsten die dann ihre Datenbanken nach Einträgen, die halt ihren Betrieb stören und schmeißen einen dann raus, damit sie halt schneller ihre Liste abgearbeitet kriegen. Und bei uns hat das so gut funktioniert. Wir haben von, ich glaube, wir sind von 20.000 Spam-Mails pro Tag jetzt in der Firma so auf 5.000 runtergekommen. Also haben die Quote von 95 auf 50 Prozent reduziert. Allein durch die Maßnahmen. Man konnte es so richtig schön sehen in der Statistik, wie das so über Wochen weg tatsächlich die Zahl der Versuche einfach zurückging, weil die angefangen haben, uns reihenweise rauszuwerfen aus ihren Datenpacken.
Der Einfachheit halber gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus, dass es diesen Button in meinem Mailer doch gibt. Ich habe mich nicht hingesetzt und angefangen, den dahin zu programmieren oder die Möglichkeit gibt. Ich habe mich nicht hingesetzt und angefangen, mir das zu schreiben. Warum hast du mit so etwas angefangen?
Tja, ich habe neulich ein Interview mit einem Hooligan, jetzt sind wir beim Fußball gesehen, wurde auch gefragt, warum wird man Hooligan? Da war auch die Antwort, man wird dazu geboren. Bei mir war es so, ich bin im Alter von 13 Jahren an einem Programmierer vorbeigelaufen, der im Kaufhaus saß und ein kleines Programm, in ein TI-99-4, glaube ich, war das damals. Ah, 4A hieß der.
Hab ich noch im Keller stehen müssen, wenn jemand den haben will.
Und jedenfalls ein Programm, wo man dann ein beliebiges Datum eingeben konnte und der Rechner warf den Wochentag aus. Und ich konnte mir, als ich das sah, beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, oder wie er das jetzt in so kurzer Zeit bewerkstelligt hatte, weil ich war damals noch damit beschäftigt, Logikbausteine und Transistoren aneinander zu löten und versuchte mir vorzustellen, wie viele Gatter ich jetzt aneinander löten müsste, um denselben Effekt zu erreichen. Und sah halt ein riesiges Grab an TTL-ICs und dachte mir, mein Gott, wenn der hier in so kurzer Zeit so etwas auf die Wege bringt, da komm ich mit Gatterlöten einfach nicht gegen an. Und das war für mich so das Ding. Ich konnte mir absolut nicht vorstellen, wie er das jetzt gemacht hat. Das war Zauberer. Und das hat mich dermaßen beunruhigt, dass ich statt nach Hause zu gehen schnurstracks aus dem Kaufhaus in die Stadtbücherei marschiert bin und mir dort, ich glaube, anderthalb Meter eigentlich alles an Büchern, was es dort zum Thema Programmieren gab, mitgenommen habe und dann durchforsted habe. Das war ziemlich krudes Zeugs damals, was mir in die Finger gefallen ist. Aber ja, so ging das dann bei mir los.
Also Beunruhigung war deine Ursprungsmotivation?
Ja, das war absolut beunruhigt. Dass da Dinge vor sich gehen, die ich nicht begreifen oder nachvollziehen kann, musste ich sofort auf den Grund gehen. Also es war für mich eine existenzielle Frage. Einfach von Weltbild und Existenz. Also ich konnte nicht leben, ohne zu wissen, wie das geht. Das ist vielleicht die einfache Erklärung. Ja, und so hat das halt seinen Anfang genommen. Dann habe ich meine Eltern so lange gequält, bis sie mir ja einen Rechner irgendwann hingestellt haben. Das hat aber eine Weile gedauert, sodass ich dann halt auf ein Blatt Papier programmieren und Rechner im Kopf gespielt habe. Also die ersten anderthalb Jahre habe ich das halt komplett im Kopf alles durchgezogen, ohne Rechner. Und naja.
Und warum bist du nicht zur Open Source gegangen wie Harald?
Ja, das ist...
Weil es kein Geld für gibt, würde ich sagen.
Nee, ich bin dann sehr früh halt dann korrumpiert worden. Damals war es noch viel einfacher. Ja, weil es gab nicht so viel Software und der Bedarf nach individueller Software war recht groß. Und ich stellte plötzlich fest, dass für Dinge, die ich sowieso auch freiwillig und ohne Geld dafür zu bekommen, ich halt auch ein sehr ordentliches Taschengeld kriegen konnte. Und da war es dann eigentlich...
Du bist in Wirklichkeit Tan Siekmann.
Was für ein Ding? Nein, also mit 15 habe ich angefangen, mich zu verkaufen. Und ja, daran hat sich bis heute nichts geändert.
Ich würde ja ganz gerne mal das Thema noch ein bisschen, was wir hier eigentlich angekündigt haben, in den Fokus nehmen.
Entschuldige meine Boulevardesken-Ausflüge hier.
Letztlich hast du ja recht, weil das ist ja die Grundlage, die Motivation. Was möchtest du denn jetzt in Django spielen?
Kurz ansagen lassen, was das hier überhaupt soll. Chaosradio 114 Software Projektmanagement ist eigentlich das Thema heute Abend im Rahmen des Blue Moon.
Auch als CCC Tele Shop bekannt? Ja, und wir haben jetzt schon eine ganze Menge geredet darüber, was so die Motivation des Programmierens ist, wie man dazukommt und wie sich auch Gruppen finden und wie man schon mal auch in unterschiedlichen Umgebungen seine Mannschaft beisammenhält. Pavel hat halt so seinen Blickwinkel in der Firma, wo er ihm auch eine ziemlich advancede Methodik zur Anwendung bringt, wo es sehr viel Ritus und sehr viel Disziplin gibt, woran sich gehalten wird. Das ist natürlich der eine Aspekt. Das andere ist eben Open Source, wo es einfach mal komplett anders läuft. Aber es gibt natürlich auch ähnlichen Bedarf. Darauf würde ich jetzt auch ganz gerne nochmal zu sprechen kommen, nämlich was man eigentlich so braucht. Weil viele Leute, gerade so die jüngeren Leute, die ich kennengelernt habe, die so mit dem Programmieren anfangen, die durchaus da ihre Skills haben und die auch keine größeren Probleme haben, jetzt so das Programmieren als solches zu verstehen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch gar nicht so schwierig. Also Programmieren an sich ist nichts Schwieriges. Letztlich ist es nur eine Fleißarbeiten, hat sehr viel mehr mit Erfahrungen zu tun, dass man da eben auch weit kommt und schöne Sachen macht. Aber alle haben eigentlich so das gleiche Problem. Und das Problem verschärft sich insbesondere dann, wenn man eben mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeitet. Und das müssen gar nicht mal unbedingt nur Leute sein, die jetzt auch wie man selbst programmiert, sondern man will ja auch zusammenarbeiten, zum Beispiel mit Leuten, die Hilfesystem machen, also quasi die Dokumentation machen für das System. Es kann ja sein, dass irgendjemand ankommt und sagt, ich finde dein Programm so toll, aber es ist eigentlich scheiße dokumentiert, ich würde das gerne machen. Das heißt, in irgendeiner Form muss man eben auch mit gemeinsamen Systemen arbeiten. In irgendeiner Form muss das koordiniert sein. Und dann muss man, glaube ich, ein paar Sachen unterscheiden. Was wir schon angesprochen haben, ist die Kommunikation. Ich meinte, Harald, okay, klassisches System ist die Mailingliste. Das ist eigentlich auch immer ganz hilfreich und das kann man jedem empfehlen, dass man eine geschlossene Mailingliste hat. Also geschlossen in dem Sinne, dass sie eigentlich nur von Leuten abonniert wird, die jetzt wirklich ganz konkret mit dem Projekt was zu tun haben. Also nicht so ein riesiger Turmelplatz, weil zu viele Leute mit zu wenig Fokus. Dann hat man schnell so Off-Topic-Diskussionen wie hier im Chaosradio. Und das ist aber immer schon ein erstaunlicher Kulturunterschied, wenn man sieht, dass wenn... Ich glaub, diese Linux-Könnel-Mailingliste, die du angesprochen hast, das ist auch wirklich ein Turmelplatz von sehr vielen Leuten, oder? Wie viele Leute sind da subscribt, Harald? Auf der Colonel-Mailingliste?
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Keine Ahnung, aber das werden mit Sicherheit, ich nehme mal an, irgendwie im hohen 5-stelligen, wenn nicht im 6-stelligen Bereich sein, die Zahl der Subscriber.
6-stelligen. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem, aber wenn man irgendwie so 2, 3, 4, 5 Leute da hat, dann ist es halt wirklich eher so ein intimes Gespräch. Und das ist hilfreich. Ich fand auch für bestimmte Situationen auch Instant Messaging sehr gut. Gerade wenn man unter so einem gewissen Zeitdruck am Projekt arbeitet, ist natürlich so etwas wie Java oder AEM, also diese ganzen Instant Messaging-Systeme, welches man da benutzt, ist eigentlich egal. Heutzutage ist der Trend auf jeden Fall in Richtung Java und XMPP. Das ist so der neue Internetstandard dafür, der sich gerade da hervortut, den auch Google benutzt. Und das kann man halt sehr schön integrieren. Das kann man auch sehr schön in seine Software integrieren. Wir haben zum Beispiel im CCC auch ein Projekt, dessen Geburt ich mal angeschoben habe, weil wir einfach eine Software brauchten, um unsere Konferenzplanung zu machen. Das hat den schönen Namen Pentabuf und ist halt so ein System, wo man eben so die ganzen Referenten einträgt und was die so für Vorträge halten wollen, wo man dann halt auswählt und dann notiert, ob das schon bestätigt wurde und so weiter, wann das stattfinden soll, um so einen Fahrplan zu machen. So ein System. Und da haben so einige Leute daran gearbeitet, aber man hat sich einfach selten, am Anfang zwar schon, aber eigentlich hat man sich selten wirklich gesehen. Man war halt nicht in der gleichen Stadt, aber man wollte ja eben dran arbeiten. Und vor allem haben auch viele Leute die ganze Zeit an so einem lebenden System gearbeitet, während andere dran programmiert haben. Und dann wurde das System halt einfach quasi so mit diesem Instant Messaging verheiratet, sodass jeder Fehler, der zur Laufzeit auftrat, automatisch den Developern zugespielt wurde. Wodurch eben die Nähe zwischen Anwendern und Entwicklern auch sehr nahe ist. Was normalerweise in solchen Systemen häufig nicht der Fall ist. Also Benutzer und Programmierer von Systemen, das sind üblicherweise wirklich sehr getrennte Welten. Aber ich kann eigentlich jedem nur empfehlen, dass man drüber nachdenken sollte, wie man eben da eine gewisse Nähe auch herstellt. Das ist natürlich bei solchen serverbasierten Anwendungen sehr viel einfacher, als wenn jetzt Leute eine Software nehmen und auf ihrem Computer einfach so einbauen. Aber es ist eben nicht so, dass es auch nicht geht. Was auch sehr erfolgreich ist, denke ich, sind Wikis. Macht ihr eigentlich, nutzt ihr Wikis in euren Projekten in irgendeiner Form?
Also wir haben einen Wiki, wo wir sehr viele Dinge dokumentieren. Also immer dann, wenn die Dinge etwas komplizierter werden oder man irgendetwas aufschreiben will, dann kommt es ins Wiki. Und auch viel Know-how, wie man sich das System baut. Oder ja, das ist ein sehr gutes Prinzip, dort alles rein zu werfen. Da findet man es wieder im Zweifelsfall. Und es macht auch nicht viel mehr Arbeit, als es irgendwie auf einem Blatt Papier, irgendwo statt auf einem Schmierzettel Dinge zu notieren, kommen sie ins Wiki. Und irgendwann merkt man dann, dass die Dinge, die vielleicht oft gebraucht werden, wie Installationsanleitungen oder irgendwelche Architekturideen oder so, dann plötzlich auch ein Eigenleben entwickeln und gepflegt werden. Und man so halt auch, ja, so eine Art Dokumentation dort entsteht, ohne dass irgendjemand sagen muss, jetzt dokumentiere das aber bitte mal. Sondern es ist dann auch ein Selbstläufer. Und ja, mittlerweile ist es sogar so, dass das Wiki, also wir haben, die Entwickler haben angefangen, das Wiki zu nutzen bei uns. Dann kamen als nächstes die Gestalter dazu, dann die Systemadministration, dann das Projektmanagement. Mittlerweile ist halt so unser ganzes Intranet eigentlich Wiki basiert, wo so Stichwort Knowledge Management eigentlich in der Firma weitestgehend über das Wiki läuft. Vor allen Dingen kann man dort auch sehr schön die ganzen anderen Dienste, die man hat, anbinden, bis hin zu so netten Gimmicks, wie ich meine, wir sind jetzt fast über 60 Leute in der Firma. Und da kann man auch nicht unbedingt jedes Gesicht zuordnen, sodass wir halt im Wiki beispielsweise aus dem LDAP direkt Mitarbeiter samt Fotos dort auslesen und ins Wiki packen. Und das funktioniert doch recht gut. Man wird es nicht missen.
Netfilter selber hat kein Wiki, und das passt auch wieder schön zu diesem Thema hier. In anderen Projekten verwende ich sehr wohl Wikis. Der Punkt von einem Wiki ist halt, dass es Leute geben muss, die sich darum kümmern, das zu managen. Erstens hat man bei Wikis, die öffentlich zugänglich sind, und nicht nur Firmen intern, ein Spamproblem, das man irgendwie lösen muss. Dann hat man das Problem, dass Leute Dinge eintragen, die nicht so richtig sind. Da muss es entsprechend wieder andere Leute geben, die das korrigieren und jemanden, der ein bisschen ein Auge drauf hat. Nicht zuletzt geht es bei Netfilter auch um Sicherheitssoftware. Und wenn die Dokumentation, wenn ihr eine kleine Änderung in irgendeinem Regelbeispiel oder sonst irgendwas macht für eine Firewall-Konfiguration, und wie viele 100 User gucken darauf und übernehmen dieses Beispiel mal so und haben dann irgendwie ihre Firewall falsch konfiguriert, das ist natürlich schon ziemlich riskant. Und ich muss ganz einfach sagen, und das zählt für die anderen Entwickler jetzt eben auch im Core-Team oder überhaupt in der Entwicklungs-Community, dass wir nicht die Zeit und die Motivation mitbringen würden, irgendwie so ein Wiki zu pflegen oder nur zur Korrektur zu lesen, die Änderungen durchzugucken. Also ich bin da persönlich niemand, der dahinter steckt. Und wenn sich jemand findet in so einem Projekt, der sowas machen möchte, cool, dann kann man das tun. Und wenn sich keiner findet, dann eben nicht. Und das ist aber halt genau jetzt ja auch im Rahmen dieser Sendung wieder interessant. Wie findet man solche Leute? Wie motiviert man die? Wie bindet man die ein? Das gehört ja auch alles zu dem Projekt und zum Management mit dazu.
Wenn man jetzt... Was für Werkzeuge setzt ihr noch ein? Vielleicht hat man noch mal das aufgreifen, was auch durch den Anrufer vorhin noch mal eingebracht wurde. Also jetzt um konkret die Softwareentwicklung als solche technisch zu unterstützen.
Ich muss aber einen Einwurf muss ich noch machen, weil ich hab das Wort gesagt, irgendwie Blog-Spammer, was gleich mir alles hat überkochen lassen. Ich bin ja ein großer Feind eigentlich der Todesstrafe. Es gibt wirklich eine Ausnahme und das sind Blog-Spammer. Blog-Spammer, das ist die niedrigste Lebensform auf Erden, die es gibt, ein asoziales Gesoxe, sowas echt von der Oberfläche dieses Planeten getilgt gehört. Also Blog-Spammer, da gibt es einfach keine Entschuldigung für, weil das sind nicht, ja, okay.
Du meinst, wenn ich jetzt in einem Blog spamme, dann gibt es keine Entschuldigung, aber wenn ich sonst spamme, gibt es dafür eine?
Ich würde ja das nicht nur auf Blog-Spammer beschränken wollen. Wie kommst du denn da jetzt überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung, aber was mir da eigentlich... Gibt es Canossa eigentlich noch? Canossa, die Veranstaltung, gibt es die noch? Ja, irgendwie in den 90ern, wo irgendwie so Admins dann immer gerne mal Spammer eingeladen haben, zum Vorträge halten, die dann auf Streckbänke montiert wurden.
Das war in der Europäer Party.
Ich, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Werkzeuge.
Werkzeuge, genau.
Schon okay, Pavel.
Ich musste das jetzt loswerden, also Block, Spam...
Ja, weil ich bin ja...
Das sind einfach Leute, die dem Fortschritt...
Asoziale Arschlöcher sind das jetzt.
Ja, schlimm.
Wir haben uns jetzt etwas aufgeregt und kommen jetzt wieder zum langweiligen technischen Teil über. Ja, also es gibt Versionskontrollsysteme. Dem aufgeschlossenen, aber noch unkundigen Zuhörer sei gesagt, es handelt sich dabei eben um Software, um die Programmierung als solche, insbesondere die Speicherung des Programmcodes zu erlauben. Wir haben das ja vorhin schon erwähnt, CVS ist das erste System, das Concurrent Versioning System. Damit ging es los und...
Na, es ging früher mit irgendwie SCCS. Ist das erste, was ich zumindest kenne. Wahrscheinlich hat das auch schon irgendwelche Vorläufer. Aber das erste, was ich kennengelernt habe, war SCCS. Dann gab es noch RCS.
CVS hat doch schon auf RCS aufgesetzt, oder? Das war es nicht so. CVS ist das erste wirklich populäre System gewesen, was auch heute noch im Einsatz ist. Was im Prinzip so ein bisschen das Grundnahrungsmittel ist. Man sollte CVS auf jeden Fall vertraut sein. So wie man als Programmierer mal C gelernt haben sollte. Nicht unbedingt ums zu programmieren, aber ums zu lesen zu können. So sollte man halt auch mit CVS umgehen können, weil sehr viel der Software, der freien Software vor allem, ist halt auch noch heute über CVS-Systeme erreichbar.
Ja und Subversion ist sehr ähnlich. Also der Umstieg von CVS, wenn man CVS und die Konzepte kennt. Oder ist der Umstieg auf Subversion auch nicht? Das wäre auch das erste eigentlich, was man sich nach dem Editor im Grunde genommen einrichtet. Also wenn man jetzt etwas größere Sachen entwickeln will, die irgendwie mehr als...
Aber ihr benutzt Subversion bei euch?
Und bei Netfilter? Subversion und Git, es kommt darauf an. Also es ist halt so, dass der Kernel selbst, der Mainline-Kernel, also so wie Linus Torwalz und Kollegen, Konsorten, das eben machen, ja im Git-Versionssystem, dem eigens dafür entwickelten, verwaltet wird. Demnach verwenden wir für die Kernel-Teile eben auch Git und für den User-Space-Sachen-Version.
Git ist jetzt dieser neue Hack von Linus Torwalz selber.
Ja, was er angefangen hat und was...
Nachdem er dieses, weil er hat auch vorher dieses kommerzielle System genutzt. Wie hieß es noch gleich?
Bitkeeper, ja.
Bitkeeper, genau.
Was wir nie genutzt haben, zum Beispiel in der Twitter-Projekt, weil wir das aus ideologischen Gründen abgelehnt haben.
Was sind das für ideologische Gründe?
Na ja, also ich mein...
Geschäftspreis Scientology oder wie?
Nein, also ich mein, es ist halt einfach so, wenn du freie Software entwickelst, dann kannst du das entweder aus rein pragmatischen Dingen tun, weil du halt irgendwie sagst, naja, es ist praktisch, dass ich einen Quellcode hab. Oder du kannst freie Software entwickeln, weil du überzeugt davon bist, dass die Freiheit, die freie Software eben bringt, also das verändern zu können und so weiter, eben ein Wert in sich ist, den du eben unterstützen möchtest. Und wenn du Software entwickelst und dich in deinem Entwicklungsprozess abhängig von etwas machst, was nicht freie Software ist, dann hast du da natürlich schon irgendwie ein latentes Problem. Und du hast eben das Tool, das Werkzeug, das du verwendest, um Software zu entwickeln, das kannst du nicht beeinflussen. Da kannst du keine Änderungen, Verbesserungen sonst irgendwas daran vornehmen. Sondern da kannst du nochmal lief an die Tür klopfen und kannst sagen, naja, wir hätten da vielleicht irgendwie dieses Feature und dann kannst du darauf hoffen, dass das vielleicht passiert oder nicht. Also das ist halt so ein Kritikpunkt an der Stelle.
Jetzt wurde mal nachgeschaut, wie viele Subscriber wirklich auf der Linux Kernel-Liste sind.
Harald. Ja, das ist richtig. Sprich? 4.900, wobei, also erstens glaube ich nicht, dass die Zahl akkurat ist. Zweitens gibt es unglaublich viele Leute, die das über NNTP Gateways oder Gmain oder derartige Dinge benutzen. Und mich überrascht die Zahl, weil wir ein Netfilter-Projekt auch schon stellenweise über 2.000 Leute hatten. Und Netfilter ist ja nun wirklich so ein Mikro-Bestandteil des Kernels. Und dass dann die Gesamtkernel-Liste von... Also da denke ich, ist an der Zahl was schief. Das kann ich nicht glauben. Auch guck dir mal die Zahl der Postings an. Also das sind irgendwie über 30.000 im Jahr oder so, was da Postings draufgehen auf die Liste.
Also...
So wo habe ich... Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich dich... Unterbrochen. War es noch bei Bitkeeper?
Nee, wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nichts weiter zu sagen.
Also ich kann auch sagen, dass wir grundsätzlich, also für unser gesamtes Toolset, auch nur Software einsetzen, die Quellcode offen ist. Und ja, eigentlich ist das einzige, was wir nutzen oder auf das wir aufsetzen, wo wir nicht über den Quellcode verfügen, ist Windows. Und ansonsten ja Windows. Und gut, jetzt Mac OS enthält halt auch leider oder OS X eine Menge Teile, wo man nicht über den Quellcode verfügt. Man kann damit leben, ach so, die Nvidia Treiber sind noch so eine etwas, also Grafikkartentreiber sind auch noch so eine etwas ärgerliche Ecke in dem ganzen für uns. Aber es ist es ist schon eine Qual eben.
Aber sag mal, warum es für dich wichtig ist, dass es frei ist.
Na wichtig ist, ist es deswegen, weil man ansonsten abhängig ist. Also jede Software enthält Fehler und weil man bestimmte Fehler, wenn man über den Quellcode nicht verfügt, man sie einfach nicht fixen kann. Das heißt, man macht sich abhängig von einem Hersteller, der plötzlich Pleite gehen kann oder der einen einfach die Anfragen ignoriert, die man an ihn stellt oder andere Dinge. Und das ist das ist einfach eine Frage jetzt der der Abhängigkeiten, in die man sich sich begibt. Und je mehr Abhängigkeiten, da kann man fast sicher sein, dass über kurz oder lang man dann ausgebremst wird und meistens dann in dem Moment, wo man es am wenigsten gebrauchen kann. Und dann ja, es garantiert einfach ein gewisses Maß an Unabhängigkeit an der Stelle und Kontrolle über sein eigenes Schicksal und das Schicksal der eigenen Software.
Ja, wollen wir dann vielleicht mal eher so noch ein bisschen in Richtung Werkzeuge weg vom Quellcode, Versionskontroll und so weiter, Management hin zu Werkzeugen, die echt so in die Management, in die Kommunikations oder überhaupt...
Vielleicht eins noch vorher, es gab unter anderem ja auch im Wiki vorher die Frage, oh Gott, was brauche ich denn alles? Und ich meine, Versionskontrolle, ich denke, das ist so das Minimum, da weiß jeder, dass man das braucht. Aber viele Leute haben halt keine Lust, sich das selber aufzusetzen. Es gibt mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Dienste im Web, die einem das halt abnehmen, also Websites, die sich ganz speziell an Developer richten, wo man so mal eben mit zwei, drei Klicks im Prinzip so die Kerninfrastruktur hat. Also vor allem bekannt, weil sie waren die ersten, wenn ich das richtig sehe, waren sie die ersten, sourceforge.net, also wenn sie nicht die ersten waren, waren sie auf jeden Fall die ersten, die wirklich richtig bekannt waren, wo halt sowas wie CVS und Subversion, also diese Source Code Kontrollsysteme drin waren, Mailinglisten drin geführt wurden, man so eine einfache Homepage hatte, so ein einfaches Forum und eben so die grundlegenden Werkzeuge. Ob man sowas nun benutzen sollte oder nicht, das ist nochmal so eine Frage für sich.
Es gibt, machen wir das Toolkit vielleicht nochmal, also aus meiner Sicht komplett. Also ganz wichtig ist dann als nächstes die Bildumgebung eigentlich. Das ist speziell für jetzt, wenn man in Sprachen, die man übersetzen muss, die halt compile und gelinkt werden müssen, hat man halt irgendeine Steuerung, die halt die bei Änderungen abhängig von den Abhängigkeiten der einzelnen Teile dann einen entsprechenden automatisierten Prozess anwirft. Und das in Verbindung mit einer Versionskontrolle, beispielsweise hilft gerade bei Multiplattformentwicklung. Wenn man das ineinander verzahnt, gerade im Team hilft das extrem. Das Änderungen oder Fehler, die jemand einbaut, sehr zeitnah erkannt werden. Das heißt also Bildsystem und dann eben ein automatisierter Bild ist das nächste, der verbunden ist mit dem Software Repository. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt eine Änderung mache an dem Quellcode und den jetzt überspiele in meinen Repository, dann gibt es einen anderen Rechner, der überwacht die ganze Zeit das Repository und guckt, hat sich da was geändert, hat sich da was geändert. Wenn sich jetzt was geändert hat, nimmt er die Änderung, kopiert sich die, also checkt die aus, und startet eben selbst den Compiler, übersetzt es, baut das. Bei uns schließen sich dann noch die automatisierten Tests an und noch ein automatisiertes Packaging. Das heißt, da ist so viel Automatisierung an der Stelle und das ist vielleicht auch so ein Hinweis oder Tipp, dass man alles, was man automatisieren kann, man möglichst auch automatisieren sollte, weil das dann einfach Fehlerquellen verhindert und ausschließt. Und gerade auch, das kam auch im Wiki, die Frage, Softwareentwicklung wird immer teurer, und wie kriegt man es halt besser und billiger hin? Und das ist wie überall Automatisierung an der Stelle ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und dass die Tools, die man hat, dann alle ineinandergreifen und einem eben Arbeit, gerade Routinearbeit, nervige Routinearbeit möglichst abnehmen und man sich auf das Wesentliche beschränken kann.
Wie heißt dieses Computersystem Array, was die ganze Zeit diese Builds macht beim Mozilla Projekt? Gibt es auch irgendeinen Namen für dieses Teil?
Gibt es irgendwie Bonsai und das ist irgendwie der Baum. Also da gibt es jedenfalls auch ein größeres.
Ja, das Mozilla Projekt ist ja insofern sehr interessant, als dass es eines der größten Open Source Projekte überhaupt ist. Und die ja auch nicht nur Software erzeugen, die auch eine ganze Menge Softwarewerkzeuge erzeugen. Also am bekanntesten ist es auch ein System, das wir so noch nicht angesprochen haben, nämlich Systeme zur Verwaltung von Fehlern. Wenn da so ein Programm draußen ist und Leute stellen halt fest, da ist irgendwas braun, dann möchte man natürlich gerne irgendeine systematische Rückmeldung haben, die dem Entwickler möglichst viel Informationen darüber gibt, wo, wann, in welchem Modul, zu welchem Zeitpunkt oder welchen Bedingungen ein Fehler aufgetreten ist und wo dann eben auch beide Seiten über einen längeren Zeitraum weiterverfolgen können, was denn nun eigentlich ist mit dieser Meldung, mit diesem Fehlerbericht. Also man nennt das einen Bug Tracker. Mozilla hat dann dieses Bugzilla Ding gemacht. Der Name ist sehr praktisch, weil das Ding kommt echt rüber wie ein Monster. Jeder, der Bugzilla benutzt, hasst es eigentlich, weil es wirklich unfassbar riesig ist. Also wenn man da einen Fehler abliefert, dann muss man, keine Ahnung, 20, 30 verschiedene Sachen ausfüllen. Man weiß bei der Hälfte überhaupt nicht, was bedeutet. Also es ist extrem für Entwickler von Entwicklern. Also man merkt so richtig, dass es so wieder mal überhaupt nicht für den End-User konzipiert wurde. Aber es gibt mittlerweile viele kleine Systeme, was wir zum Beispiel verwendet haben, was ganz nett ist. Das ist ein System, das heißt Track, T-R-A-C. Und das ist auch so ein einfacher Bugtracker, der allerdings noch zwei schöne Eigenschaften hat. Erstmal lässt er sich sehr gut verheiraten mit diesem Versionskontrollsystem, mit diesem Subversion. Das heißt, man merkt, man kann das eben so gut verbinden, so dass wenn irgendein Fehler gemeldet wurde und dieser Fehler wurde auch behoben, dann kann man eben auch gleich in demselben System ganz konkret diese Änderungen im Code sehen. Was einerseits gut für Entwickler ist, andererseits so für Power-User. Also das ist alles sehr schön miteinander verwoben. Und sie haben auch noch so ein kleines Wiki mit dran gedonnert, so dass man das eben auch noch leicht dokumentieren kann. Das ist ein sehr praktisches System. Ich mag zwar das Wiki nicht, aber ich finde die Idee von Track ganz gut. Was verwenden ihr so als Fehlerrückmeldungssystem?
Also ich bin Bugsilla-Fan, muss ich sagen. Hängt halt auch damit zusammen, dass ja, also ich bin Entwickler, ich kann mit dem System gut umgehen. Ich finde, dass man kann da auch schön das integrieren. Also gerade so die Kommunikation auch zwischen Versions-Tracker und Bugsilla. Also man kann dann so Dinge machen, dass man, wenn man eine Änderung im Versions-Kontrollsystem eincheckt und da in einem bestimmten Format irgendwie halt reinschreibt, das schließt jetzt diesen oder jenen Bug, dass das dann dort automatisch übernommen wird und dann eben den Bug im Bug-Tracker schließt, zum Beispiel solche Dinge. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich persönlich bin ein großer Bugsilla-Fan in der Hinsicht.
Also es ist einfach, ja, für Entwickler ist es okay.
Gut abgehangen sozusagen.
Gut abgehangen. Es ist auch, also mit den Mails verschicken. Also es passt. Also wir haben jetzt nicht unbedingt den Bedarf. Also man kann es an alles anpassen. Es ging auch relativ schnell, das einzurichten. Und es eignet sich nicht so sehr, wenn man jetzt Kunden direkt Bugreports machen lassen will. Das kann man vergessen. Da braucht man wahrscheinlich irgendwas anderes. Aber so für die Entwickler ist das wunderbar.
Ja, Chaosradio, Software, Projektmanagement. Jetzt haben wir schon einige Tools aufgezählt, aber was mir gerade so ein bisschen gefehlt hat ist Dokumentation. Was benutzt ihr denn da? Also wie macht ihr das mit der Dokumentation? Habt ihr Dokumentation?
RTFS sag ich da mal nur dazu. Was?
Use the source loop.
Ja, nein.
Eine andere Umschreibung des Programmierers für leck mich am Arsch.
Ja, nein. Natürlich haben wir Dokumentation. Was für eine Frage. Sie ist nur irgendwie vier Jahre alt. Nein. Wir verwenden im Netfilter-Projekt und auch in allen anderen Projekten, in denen ich involviert bin, keine Tools zur automatischen Generierung von Dokumentation. Also es gibt ja so Systeme wie zum Beispiel Doxigen, das ist ein bekanntes davon, wo man als Entwickler im Quellcode, als Kommentar sozusagen in einen bestimmten Syntax hineinschreibt, ja, jetzt diese Funktion hat diesen oder jenen Parameter und was weiß ich, wo man dann so eine kleine Dokumentation macht. Das ist eine Art Referenzdokumentation zu Softwaremodulen. Sowas verwenden wir nicht. Ja, mag durchaus sinnvoll sein, aber ist halt die Frage, was für eine Dokumentation will ich haben. Solche Systeme zur automatischen Dokumentationsgenerierung eignen sich meiner Meinung nach eben zur internen Dokumentation von irgendwelchen Schnittstellen, von Bibliotheken, von sonstigen Dingen. Aber jetzt Anwenderdokumentation oder Ähnliches automatisch aus dem Programm heraus zu generieren oder so, glaube ich nicht, dass das irgendwie Sinn hat oder überhaupt funktionieren kann. Das heißt, wir schreiben Dokumentationen völlig getrennt von Software. Bei uns wird Dokumentation in Dogbook geschrieben als Format. Und ja, da gibt es unterschiedliche Leute, die Dokumentation schreiben. Es gibt Leute, die Dokumentation übersetzen im Projekt zum Beispiel. Also wir haben auch chinesische Dokumentation zum Beispiel.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, ich sage, ich schreibe Dokumentation unabhängig von Software. Manchmal sitzen die jahrelang und schreiben nur Dokumentation. Irgendwie so Fantasiedokumentation. Also nicht unabhängig von Software.
Also bei uns ist es auch so, dass die Endbenutzer-Doku auch von Hand geschrieben wird. Ansonsten setzen wir aber schon eine ganze Menge automatisierter Verfahren ein. Also Doxygen auch, wobei ich sagen muss, dass die Nützlichkeit sich eher in Grenzen hält. Tatsächlich im Vergleich zu einer ordentlichen Struktur, einer vernünftigen Benamung und einer verständlichen Software. Wenn das stimmt, kann man fast auf Doxygen wieder verzichten, weil das ist dann auch nur unnötiges Geschwafel. Wenn man vernünftige Konventionen hat, wie Fehler signalisiert werden, wie Variablen benannt werden, wie Ownership von Objekten gemanagt wird, dann stehen die wichtigen Dinge sowieso nicht in der Doxygen Dokumentation drin. Beziehungsweise kann man sich dann auch selber durch Hingucken erschließen, was automatisch daraus kommt. Was wäre aber eine nette Sache, die wir machen, sind Tutorials, die wir schreiben, die verlinkt sind, aber mit unserem automatischen Bildsystem. Weil ein Problem ist, wenn man Tutorials mit Beispielen hat, dass sich irgendwas ändert und es ist nichts ärgerlicher, als wenn man in der Dokumentation ein Beispiel hat, was nicht funktioniert. Und deswegen werden unsere Tutorials, also die Beispiele in den Tutorials, mit automatisch getestet im Bildprozess. Und die visuellen Ergebnisse werden halt auch automatisch generiert, sodass man an der Stelle eben immer funktionierende Tutorials hat. Das finde ich einfach großartig.
Oder sie zumindest die realen Fehler enthalten, die dann auch tatsächlich drin sind.
Kleiner Scherz so von Nachrichten.
Ganz besondere Zeiten, erfordern ein ganz besonderes Radio.
So jetzt komm ich nämlich. Otto Dumke, was sagt ihr das? Nichts.
Mit einer besonders besonderen Besonderheit. Alle Spiele der deutschen Nationalelf werden live kommentiert von Tommy Wosch und Marco Seifert.
Aufkampfverteilung ist relativ klar, der Marco ist zuständig für Stammeln, Stottern, viel Information und die für große Emotionen Fakten, Fakten, Fakten.
Also immer wenn Deutschland spielt, Fernseher an, Ton aus, Radio laut. Dann Deutschland sehen und Wosch und Seifert hören.
Morgen Nachmittag geht's weiter mit Deutschland gegen Argentinien.
Jürgen, ab 17 Uhr mit Tommy Wosch und Marco Seifert.
Nach dem Einmarsch israelischer Truppen in den Gaza-Streifen hat die Europäische Union die Konfliktparteien zur Mäßigung gemahnt. EU-Außenkommissarin Ferero Waldner sagte, beide Seiten müssten einen Schritt zurück machen, um eine unkontrollierbare Krise zu verhindern. Sie forderte, die Palästinenser nachdrücklich auf den verschleppten israelischen Soldaten freizulassen, von Israel verlangte sie, eine diplomatische Lösung zu ermöglichen. Die Große Koalition erwägt einen Zeitungsbericht zufolge eine völlig neue Steuer zur Finanzierung der Gesundheitsreform. Das Bundesfinanzministerium sei beauftragt worden, Modelle für eine solche Gesundheitssteuer durchzurechnen, berichtet die Süddeutsche Zeitung unter Berufung auf mehrere Koalitionsvertreter. Mehrere tausend Schüler und Studenten haben in Wiesbaden und Hamburg gegen Studiengebühren und Verschlechterungen im Bildungsbereich demonstriert. Nach Bayern, Baden-Württemberg, Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen beschloss am Abend Hamburg die Einführung von Semestergebühren ab Sommer 2007. Hessen will ab Herbst 2007 Gebühren erheben. Nach insgesamt vier Fällen von vermissten Patienten verschärfen die Berliner Krankenhäuser ihre Sicherheitssysteme. Wie die Berliner Zeitung berichtet, sollen in den Vivantes Kliniken Demenzkranke mit elektronischen Armbändern ausgestattet werden. Außerdem sollen Bewegungsmelder in Bereichen installiert werden, die nur vom Personal betreten werden dürfen. Zum Fußball. Bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft ist heute erneut spielfrei. Die FIFA benannte am Abend den Slowaken Lubosz Michael als Schiedsrichter der Partie Deutschland gegen Argentinien am Freitag in Berlin. Das deutsche Team geht ohne verletzte Spieler in das Spiel. Die Aufstellung wird Jürgen Klinsmann aber wohl erst morgen bekannt geben. Heute Nacht ist es zunehmend gering bewölbt und trocken bei 15 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab, bei maximal 23 bis 25 Grad. Die Landstraße 33, Manchnow Richtung Höhno, ist an der Kreuzung Höhno nach einem schweren Unfall voll gesperrt. Und A100 Stadtring Berlin, Wilmersdorf Richtung Wedding. Zwischen Hohenzollern Damm und Spandauer Damm gibt es Instandhaltungsarbeiten. Dort ist der linke Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, 5 nach halb 1.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Und zwar Chaosradio 140. Wir haben uns unheimlich gefreut, darauf mit Axel gleich telefonieren zu können. Axel, halt durch. Wir haben ein kleines Problem mit diesem unglaublich hochqualitativen Touchscreen-Telefonanlagen-Computer-Gedöns. Das verhält sich nämlich gerade sehr eigenartig. Bleib einfach dran, Axel. Wir kriegen dich schon. Wir kriegen dich schon, kurz vor eins.
Wir sind jetzt im Endspurt. Gegen Ende sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen ein paar von den sozialen Aspekten der Software-Projekt-Management noch mal ansprechen, wo wir so viel Technisches haben fallen lassen. Was brennt euch denn auf dem Herzen, Jungs?
Ich hatte noch das Thema Ehrlichkeit in der Software-Entwicklung.
Harald möchte gerne das Mikrofon eingeschaltet bekommen.
Steuerung alt entfernt.
Während sich Holger mit seinem Windows-Computer rumärgert, sagte Pabel.
Ja, Ehrlichkeit.
Ehrlichkeit ist wichtig.
Ehrlichkeit ist wichtig. Ehrlichkeit ist wichtig, ja, weil eben es oft genau daran mangelt. Also es fängt schon mal an, natürlich das große Problem Ehrlichkeit zu sich selbst. Wie viel kann man tatsächlich schaffen in einer bestimmten Zeit? Das fällt praktisch jedem. Also ich kenne kaum Programmierer oder Entwickler, die sich nicht überschätzen würden oder nicht den Zeitaufwand unterschätzen, den es braucht, eine bestimmte Aufgabe zu erledigen, die sie vorher so noch nicht erledigt haben. Wenn man etwas schon mal gemacht hat, kann man das ganz gut einschätzen, aber gerade bei neuen Dingen. Aber das Ganze wird natürlich im Team, kann das natürlich sehr schnell fatal werden. Auch im kommerziellen Umfeld, wenn man für einen Kunden arbeitet, dann fällt es auch oft sehr schwer, jetzt schlechte Nachrichten zu überbringen. Oder man versucht sich dann irgendwie, um unangenehme Wahrheiten herumzumogeln. Und wir hatten irgendwo Tollcollect, auch wieder als typisches Beispiel, wo es an verschiedenen Stellen einfach an Ehrlichkeit offenbar gemangelt hat, wo das Projekt von Leuten geplant wurde und Zeiten festgelegt wurden, ohne dass man jemanden mal gefragt hat, wie lange dauert es wirklich? Das heißt, man war schon mal ganz am Anfang gegenüber dem Kunden, in dem Fall der Regie, einfach nicht ehrlich.
Die wollten aber auch nicht, dass man ehrlich war zu ihnen, oder? Also ist es eine Frage des Kunden?
Ja, man kann natürlich sagen, der Kunde will manchmal belogen werden, oder will die Wahrheit nicht hören. Das habe ich auch oft genug erlebt, dass ich gesagt habe, es wird nicht rechtzeitig fertig. Und dann bin ich teilweise ignoriert worden, so nach dem Motto, wie kann der jetzt schon sechs Wochen vorher wissen, dass es nicht fertig wird? Er hat doch immerhin noch sechs Wochen Zeit, können die dann nicht einfach schneller arbeiten?
Da ist Tollcollect natürlich ein wunderbares Beispiel für, also das musste aus politischen Gründen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt fertig werden. Und es wäre auch egal gewesen, selbst wenn alle gesagt hätten, das wird nicht fertig, Herr Stolpe hätte gesagt, das ist dann fertig. Das ist genauso wie dieses Studio hier, das war auch noch nicht fertig, als wir hier eingezogen sind, aber der Sender war zehn Jahre alt.
Gerade bei politisch initiierten Großprojekten, da brauchen wir ja nicht nur Tollcollect anschauen, da können wir uns die Gesundheitskarte zum Beispiel anschauen, zu der wir nächsten Monat eine Sendung machen.
Toll, jetzt haben wir schon das Thema.
Ja, dann können wir jetzt nach Hause gehen. Politiker werden in gewissen Jahreszyklen gewählt und sitzen bestimmte Zahl von Jahren irgendwie in einem Ministerium und die müssen dann eben Projekte initiieren, die vor dem Ende der Rahmzeit fertig werden. Aber das ist jetzt kein spezifisches Softwareentwicklungsproblem.
Und es kostet nicht ihr Geld. Ich glaube, das ist auch immer wieder abhängig davon, ob das das eigene Geld kostet oder nicht.
Das sind auch nochmal ganz andere Aspekte. Aber das mit der Ehrlichkeit und mit den zeitlichen Abschätzungen usw. das kann ich auch so bestätigen. Also ich kenne kein Projekt, das jemals irgendwie früher fertig geworden wäre, als die Prognosen und die Aussagen so immer angegeben haben bzw. eben vereinbart waren. Das ist sicherlich ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt, der natürlich bei kommerzieller Softwareentwicklung eine ganz andere Rolle spielt. Also es gibt so eine Aussage zur freier Softwareentwicklung, die von Alan Cox stammt. Das ist auch ein sehr bekannter Linux Kernentwickler und freier Software-Enthusiast, der sagt, also freie Software ist per Definition zu spät, weil die Entwicklung von freier Software beginnt dann, wenn irgendein Entwickler ein konkretes Problem hat, das er lösen will. Wohingegen bei kommerzieller Software, also jetzt bei zumindest Massen-Software, ist es so, dass sich also irgendwie ein Product Marketing Department Gedanken macht, zu welchem Zeitpunkt könnte man dann ein Produkt mit diesem oder jenem Funktionsumfang gut auf dem Markt verkaufen und dann wird entwickelt, dass es dann fertig ist, wenn man denkt, dass es sich auf dem Markt gut verkauft. Und es wird nicht erst angefangen zu entwickeln, wenn der Markt schon den Bedarf hat.
Das Telefon geht übrigens wieder. Wollen wir mal versuchen, ob Axel noch da unter dem Knopf ist?
Guten Morgen, Hiram.
Ah, nix für ungut. Musstest du jetzt nochmal anrufen oder haben wir dich auf den Keller geholt?
Das sind zwei von einander unabhängige Systeme. Also das, was hier einfriert und abschmiert hat.
Das ist nur das Frontend, wie das so in Neudeutsch heißt.
Okay, jetzt spricht das Backend zu uns. Was hast du auf dem Herzen?
Genau. Ja, ich hab ganze Zeit euch zugehört und hab festgestellt, dass ich irgendwie einen netten Spagat zwischen all den Problemen habe bei mir auf Arbeit. Auf der einen Seite genau das, was beim Extreme Programming auftritt. Wir haben eine Idee, was wir machen wollen. Während das Programm das erste Mal in seiner Beta-Testphase dem Nutzer in die Hand gegeben wird, stellt sich heraus, was er eigentlich wirklich machen will. Ich muss dazu vielleicht das Randbedingung vorausschicken. Ich arbeite in einem Institut der Grundlagenforschung. Da ist einfach von vornherein noch nicht so abzusehen, was denn überhaupt passieren soll und in welche Richtung das Messsystem überhaupt entwickelt werden soll. Wir wissen, wir haben die und die Teile, die wollen wir bewegen. Ja, irgendwie. Aber spätestens bei der Frage, wie wollen wir denn die Teile bewegen? Und in welche Richtung und welche Parameter wollen wir gleichzeitig oder nacheinander ändern? Die Frage ist bei Beginn der Softwareentwicklung irgendwie noch so weit in den Sternen, dass keiner so prophetisch veranlagt ist, dass er damit was anfangen kann. Auf der anderen Seite, spätestens wenn der erste damit vernünftig messen kann, wird das allen Nutzern, die bei uns dann als Gäste kommen, zur Verfügung gestellt. Und die wollen alle damit messen. Die haben dann alle Ideen, was sie dann alles noch irgendwie geändert haben möchten. Das ist wirklich eine richtig spannende Geschichte. Auf der einen Seite ist man ohne CVS relativ erschossen, zugegebenerweise, weil manche Sachen gehen irgendwie nur drei Versionen zuvor. Dabei fällt mir ein, was liebe ich OpenVMS oder sein Vorgänger, der auch ohne der Vorsilbe Open auskam, als es noch ohne, dass ich mir auch nur im geringsten Gedanken darum machen musste, die Software ganz alleine immer wieder eine neue Version abgelegt hat und hinten eine Versionsnummer dran gehängt hat. Es hat nie wieder jemand geschafft, so ein Dateisystem zu entwickeln.
Wobei es sich aber auch immer nur auf eine Datei bezog.
Ja gut, aber ich hatte zumindest die Chance zu sagen, ich konnte sogar dem Linker sagen, nimm bitte die Datei mit Versionsnummer 58 statt 60. Überhaupt kein Problem gewesen. So was ist heute einfach nicht mehr drin. Ich habe nie wieder ein System gefunden, was das kann.
Dann schreib doch eins.
Der Bedarf scheint nicht besonders groß zu sein. Ich hab mir auch schon häufiger Gedanken gemacht, ob man sowas nicht haben will.
Ich glaube einfach, es haben sich zu viele Leute mit den Krankheiten einfach arrangiert, mit denen sie arbeiten müssen.
Es gibt verschiedene versionierende Filesysteme Oracle hat z.B. auch eins im Angebot.
Stimmt, richtig. Läuft das mit der HP UX 1020? Nein, gut, lassen wir das.
Worauf wolltest du denn eigentlich hinaus?
Das Problem ist, es ist immer wieder spannend, den großen theoretischen Erörterungen zuzuhören, die man irgendwann auch im Studium über Softwareentwicklung gehört hat, bis man da das erste Mal über so ein Problem stolpert, was irgendwie da überhaupt nicht drin ist. Also wirklich ganz und gar nicht drin ist, weil die ganze Theorie, also auf der einen Seite, die klassische Theorie sagt, wir schreiben ein Lastenheft und ein Pflichtenheft und wenn wir damit fertig sind, ist die Entwicklung so, hat uns die Wissenschaft so weit überholt, dass wir uns das eigentlich sparen können, was wir uns in die Tonne treten können.
Was für Probleme sind denn das, die da bei euch auftreten?
Na ja, also im Endeffekt, das Ganze basiert auf einem mehr oder weniger Echtzeitsystem. Also es ist ein Echtzeitsystem. Ganz unten drunter liegt ein VXWorks von Windriver. Darauf basierend läuft ein Internetprojekt, was sich EPIX nennt. Experimental Physics and Industrial Control System. Was mag ich jetzt nicht lang und breit auseinandersetzen. Es ist im Prinzip ein Projekt, was irgendwo in den USA mal gestartet worden ist, an einer Beschleunigereinrichtung. Ich glaube in Los Alamos. Und was sich als relativ brauchbares System entwickelt hat, um viele kleine Rechner miteinander zu vernetzen, die alle untereinander Daten austauschen. Das bekanntste System, was damit gesteuert wird, ist das European South Observatory, die unter ihren Spiegeln endlos viele Stempel haben, um die Termine aus den Spiegel...
Ich komme doch mal zu eurem spezifischen Problem.
Und die Sache ist einfach die, darauf basierend mithilfe dieses Systems baust du also irgendwie eine Steuerung, mithilfe derer du in der Lage bist, optische Elemente, sagen wir mal ganz einfach, optische Elemente zu bewegen. Und jetzt kommt der Nutzer und sagt, ja ich möchte aber das so bewegen, und das so bewegen, und das so bewegen. Und das möglichst gleichzeitig und möglichst synchron, und das eben nicht synchron, und wenn das fertig ist, dann das so und dann das so. Sowie du das, okay, hören wir zu, reden wir in einer Woche drüber, kannst du so fahren. Kaum bist du damit fertig, kommt der nächste und sagt, ja so wollen wir es aber nur gerade nicht. Und das darf also keinesfalls passieren, und das darf also sich überhaupt nicht bewegen. Dafür muss ich das und das und das bewegen.
Ja, da hast du also sozusagen das typische Problem, dass du keine klare Vorgabe hast, wer sozusagen dein Auftraggeber ist, der dir spezifiziert, wie jetzt das Interface aussehen soll.
Das Problem ist, das wird es nie geben. Das wird es einfach nie geben. Weil selbst derselbe Nutzer, der mir vor 14 Tagen sagte, ich möchte das und das und das bewegen, der macht das jetzt 14 Tage und stellt fest, ja Mist, ja ist nicht schlecht, das tut auch das, was ich dir gesagt habe, aber es nützt mir so überhaupt nichts. Ich muss doch bitte das festhalten und das bewegen und den Parameter am besten symmetrisch mit dem Parameter ändern. Weil Grundlagenforschung, das gab es einfach noch nie. Und an der Stelle bist du also mit so einem Projekt, also es ist immer ein Running System. Es gibt nie irgendwie das System, was gerade läuft. Du hast eigentlich fast an jedem Experiment, auch wenn die Hardware an vielen Fällen gleich aussieht, hast du nicht im Experiment ein anderes System.
Ich denke, das hat mit der Grundlagenforschung jetzt auch gar nicht so viel zu tun. Das sieht man in vielen Softwareprojekten ganz generell. Dass die Definition des Anforderungsprofil sich dynamisch ändert im Laufe der Zeit, fortentwickelt usw. sehe ich auch grundsätzlich als kein großes Problem an. Man muss das mit der Abrechnung konkretisieren. Wann ist das Projekt abgeschlossen? Was ist dann Folgeauftrag usw.?
Ich bin also kein freier Entwickler. Ich bin also einfach angestellt bei diesem Institut. Die Sache ist tatsächlich, die ein einzelner Nutzer ist tatsächlich eine messbare Größe. Mit der wirklich ein Wunsch hat. Wir müssen nicht warten, bis 20 Leute sich zusammengefunden haben, die sagen, wir wollen das machen. Die ein Einziger ist eine kennbare Größe.
Wie wir mit wechselnden Anforderungen umgehen, ist eine Methode aus dem Extreme Programming, die Priorisierung. Das heißt, man versucht es eben auch transparent zu machen, wie lange bestimmte Dinge dauern. Er lässt dem Kunden die Wahl der Entscheidung. Und was ganz wichtig ist, ihm klar zu machen, dass er nicht alles haben kann. Dass jede Entscheidung, die er trifft, auch zwei Seiten einer Medaille sind. Das heißt, eine Mark oder ein Entwicklertag kann nur einmal ausgegeben werden. Und dann muss der Nutzer einfach Entscheidungen treffen. Und da ist es gut, eben auch wieder an der Stelle das Thema Ehrlichkeit und Transparenz und das entsprechend zu strukturieren. Manchmal gerät man dann natürlich, das ist dann die besonders ärgerliche Variante, wenn man dann an Leute gerät, die dann zwar erstmal priorisieren, aber nachdem man dann die Sachen erster Priorität abgearbeitet hat und die Sachen, gegen die sie sich entschieden haben, dann plötzlich doch noch haben wollen. Das sind dann so die Momente, wo einem dann doch manchmal einfach der Kragen platzt.
Axel, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, das scheint halt immer wieder so das Problem zu sein, so diese Sache mit den Anforderungen. Und wie macht ihr denn das eigentlich? Wie notiert ihr eigentlich so Feature-Wünsche? Das ist halt auch immer so ein großes Problem, was ich sehe. Also wie bringt man diese ganzen Wünsche und Anforderungs- also Verbesserungsvorschläge?
Was ich mich ja frage ist, warum kriegt ihr das nicht hin? Warum kriegt ihr es nicht hin, euren Kunden zu sagen, so ist es und so bleibt es? Entschuldige. Weil das klingt so, ich weiß nicht, ich hab früher mal Daily Soaps produziert. Und da hatten wir montags um 10 war die Produktionsbesprechung. Und alles, was nicht in der Produktionsbesprechung gesprochen wurde, war nicht existent. Und da gab es überhaupt keine Verhandlungen drüber. Und da konnten Kostümbildner noch hundertmal kommen und sagen, ja, ich brauch aber, ne, gibt's nicht.
Nee, so läuft es dann aber. Da muss man aber auch dann einen bestimmten Stand, ne Konsequenz und Disziplin an den Tag legen, ohne jetzt aber dann unfreundlich zu...
Das ist immer das Komplizierte wahrscheinlich.
Genau, freundlich, aber bestimmt an manchen Stellen. Und eben, ja, möglichst gleich vom Anfang an versuchen, ne Vertrauensbeziehung herzustellen. Da ist auch, XP, ich kann auch nochmal auf unsere, noch auf die Chaosradio Express Sendung an der Stelle verweisen, wo es ganz gut erläutert haben, wie man halt am Anfang eines Projekts ne Vertrauensbeziehung herstellt, indem man über Ängste redet, die halt auf beiden Seiten bestehen, wenn man so ne Entwicklungsbeziehung beginnt. Und wenn man sich darüber am Anfang offen austauscht, dann fällt es auch leichter im Verlauf wirklich ehrlich, sich auszutauschen und das Ganze halbwegs vernünftig zu steuern.
Ihr meint gerade einer im Chat, man sollte jedem größeren Entwicklerteam einen Psychologen zur Seite stellen.
Ja, also gute Entwicklungsleiter sind eigentlich auch, haben, hab ich durchaus gewisse psychologische, ja, Erfahrungen, Einfühlungsvermögen, soziale Kompetenz.
Und auf dem Mailing, das sie niedermachen? Es gibt Leute, die schwören auf solche Systematiken.
Ja, also Steve Jobs wird nachgesagt, dass er irgendwie als Entwicklungsleiter diese Art von Führungsstil hat. Hier nehmen wir die Leute, nachdem sie 90 Stunden die Woche entwickelt haben, dann noch komplett rund gemacht hat. Echt? So nach dem Motto.
Ich kenne den Produktionsleiter vom Film, der hat deswegen mal eins auf die Fresse gekriegt.
Diesen Dreck will ich hier in meinem System nicht sehen. Alles weg, nochmal neu schreiben. So solche Sachen sollen da...
Man wundert sich, dass er überhaupt Erfolg hat mit dieser Methode.
Stephen Jobs hat deswegen mal eins auf die Fresse gekriegt.
Ach so, okay. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sich jemand sowas auf Dauer gefallen lässt.
Es gab da Handgreiflichkeiten in seinem Team.
Was für ein wunderbares Ende zum Thema Software-Entwicklungsmanagement.
Genau. Entweder freundlich sein oder es gibt eins auf die Fresse.
Die Werlachos, die Werlachos.
Das war Chaosradio 114. Im Studio waren Harald, Fabio und Tim. Chaosradio 115 wird sich beschäftigen mit der Gesundheitskarte, also mit dieser Chipkarte, die wir bald gezwungen werden zu benutzen, wo dann irgendwie unsere Daten drauf sind. Ich hab gesagt, mein Gott, trägt das denn drei Stunden? Und habe erfahren, dass es nicht nur um eine Chipkarte geht, sondern um ein einmal umkrempelndes Gesundheitssystem, zumindest der Datenerfassung und Verarbeitung in diesem System.
Genau, die Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens sozusagen.
Das wird hoch spannend, das wird hoch interessant, das wird relativ wenig Technik und sehr viel Soziokulturelles beinhalten, vermute ich mal.
Ah, da gibt es auch viel Technisches. Unsere Mischung halt.
Unsere Mischung halt. Erzählt es weiter, da gibt es dann wirkliche Neuigkeiten, die auch noch nicht in der Zeitung stehen. Natürlich stehen dann erst in drei Jahren drin, wenn diese Karte längst eingeführt ist und wir darunter leiden. Am 26. Juli, am 26. Juli, da gibt es das Chaosradio 115, denn das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Die frische Datenschleuder ist raus, so findet ihr unter www.ccc.de.
Genau. Es gibt Chaosradio auch als Podcast unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Diese Sendung, alle anderen Sendungen, das ganze Archiv. Da gibt es jetzt übrigens auch den ganzen letzten Kongress, den 22. Chaos Communication Kongress, 22C3. Vom letzten Jahr gibt es jetzt auch als Audio- und Videopodcast zum Abonnieren. Es gibt die Datenschleuder dort als Podcast zu abonnieren. Und vor allem gibt es auch noch Chaosradio Express, das Chaosradio für zwischendurch, was nicht immer ganz so lang ist wie diese Sendung. Aber dafür wird auch nicht so laut gelacht. Und wir hoffen, dass das auch nach wie vor ein Angebot ist, was euch berührt. Und wenn dem so ist oder auch wenn dem nicht so ist, dann könnt ihr uns immer Feedback schicken an Chaosradio at ccc.de. Das ist immer gerne gesehen, auch wenn ihr nichts Konkretes habt. Wir freuen uns über jede Rückmeldung. Das hält auch uns am Leben. Und ja, das solltet ihr tun.
Im Folgenden der Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf. Danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.
Und jetzt gibt es noch ein bisschen...
Ich hab schon Tschüss gesagt.
Ja, aber ich hab doch hier noch den Musikwunsch. Ist das jetzt meine Musik oder ist das deine Musik? Okay, naja gut, dann werd ich das jetzt...
Du wirst jetzt noch mal so eine richtig schöne Miese... Pause reinhauen.
Genau, wie das so ein unprofessioneller DJ macht.
Aber du bist ja Podcaster. Woher sollst du wissen, wann der Sack zu ist?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab hier noch eine Maus, irgendwie keinen ordentlichen Regler. Das ist alles elend. Schlimm, oder?
Ja, das Radio wird sterben.
Na dann... Schicken wir euch jetzt erstmal in die Warteschleife. Bis bald, tschüss.